[Music]
we are back
what's going on akw what's going on
brother
kid creed i see that game played over
here funny with the ratio
i don't play with the numbers but i
don't i don't know what's going on
but i don't play with doubles but
hustling motivate my guy
always giving him love let me see if i
can get his name right home
pycon pycon fusion what's going on mafa
what's going on gen x one two eight show
guy what's going on rocker corey what it
is y'all know what it is it's a big day
today
it's a big day oh i appreciate you
hustling you're already on your job i
appreciate you bro you have no idea
yeah man big show today in the room you
already know what it is you know it's
gonna be spicy
a little adjacent in the realm it's
always a good time um
yeah man let's go and have some fun now
i've seen some comments in the comment
section from a few of y'all
look i always got this this model you
know if we're gonna have guests on
that not everyone agrees with and um at
the end of the day
it's on you it's your personal decision
whether you choose you know to support
us or not but
come back next week that's all i can say
because we're going to continue to have
guests on
we're not going to be closed-minded and
not listen to other people's opinions
if they slightly differ from us or they
completely agree with us so
that's what it is disclaimer out the
window but anyway we're going to have
some fun today y'all
waiting for attic i see them in the room
i know what's going on i spoke to kid
yes they mean the king hung out
yesterday was a lot of fun
them pull up we're gonna have a little
show man a lot of good topics you
already know
tcl delegation stand up dicks
dude ripper slaughter you already know
so yeah we'll get jason in here in a few
and
buckle up all that good stuff we're
gonna get into some real
gaming discussions in the industry talk
to you adam
you know i gotta shout y'all follow the
super chat just showing support i can't
wait to see the
star field xbox series x and playstation
5
you messy sir you
bestie sir but no doubt don't feel gonna
be late see you at the finish
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh i
guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really watch that joke king david
still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
on the lord's day
[Laughter]
and also live on lords of episode number
209
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
day
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got
press reset 20 years of xbox
25 playstation studio games and yakuza
like a dragon to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who in my opinion is
not only the definitive investigative
reporter within our modern era of video
games
but whose stellar track record combined
with an empathy for game development
has easily solidified his outstanding
reputation
in games journalism wow what an
feel like my wife intro be saying every
time i walk into the room i want my i
want
actually i want to play i want to record
that record and then throw that back in
the boardroom
but we ain't finished jason introducing
the video game reporter for bloomberg
news co-host of the triple click podcast
and author of blood sweat and pixels
in addition to his latest book press
reset
the lord of human stories passionate jet
fan
with the most legendary twitter figures
in the game
live from my new york state and making
his return
into the realm of the lords my man
lord jason schreier how you doing sir
what's up guys
thank you all for having me and thank
you thank you
cognino for the kind words i appreciate
it oh it's a pleasure sir always a
pleasure sir first of all
what have you been playing and um let's
talk about twitter for a second because
you've been real loose okay so first of
all so games i just uh
literally like seconds ago just before
logging on to zoom
for this podcast i was playing mass
effect which is has sucked me back in
playing the remaster it's a great
remaster and i haven't played those
games since they originally came out um
so 2007 for the first one and so i
barely remember any of it
it's been like 15 years and so i'm
playing it and i'm like man this game is
so good
it's still so good so i'm really
enjoying that i might actually
play through the whole trilogy which
would be crazy but yeah really into it
and yeah twitter is a fun topic i just
like a few minutes before we recorded i
saw someone tweeting at you
being like i was blocked by jason and
someone asked why and he was like
because i disagreed with him and so of
course it took me 10 seconds to find out
that uh
that actually he like called me an
[ __ ] and like said my journalism
and i'm like man you're like every
single time someone says they were
blocked for disagree i've never
once block me block someone for
disagreeing with me unless they're like
annoying in some way or another
um every single time it takes me like 10
seconds to find a tweet where they're
just like
calling me a prick or something like
that i mean it's just like like why you
gotta lie why are you gonna lie if
you're gonna call someone name
like accept it except that you're an
[ __ ]
so so if somebody engages you nicely
they aren't getting blocked no i mean
unless there are like times
first of all i've never used a block
list and second of all there are times i
it's all manual and there are times when
like if if people are like dog piling
like a bunch of people are saying the
same thing and i'm like clearly this is
coming from 4chan or something like that
or like a reddit or whatever or if if
if like if you decide to like i don't
know just like
like come after me for no reason then
i'm
probably gonna block you if you're
disagreeing with something i said i will
never block you oh that's not because
because a lot of people thought that a
lot of people felt like oh never
just like i've had i disagree with him
yeah no i've had some really interesting
conversations with people who disagree
with me and and disagree with my
thoughts on something and that's totally
fine there's nothing wrong with that
if someone's like you're a liar and your
reporting is wrong then i'm probably
going to block it
okay if someone is like actually i
disagree with what you said about
xbox or whatever then you're not going
to get blocked for that i feel like you
know what it is jason i think
you make some valid points and the thing
i i feel is that
a lot of social media i love having
discourse where you do disagree right i
feel that's healthy
but i do agree with you in the sense
that once people cross the line of being
disrespectful
then i'm the same way like it's off with
your head because at that point
we're not engaging intelligently you're
just trying to be hurtful about certain
things and
again this people disagree with me all
the time me and sorry we had a podcast
disagreed about mass effect which was
better like that's my brother and at the
end of the day i still love them and all
that
same thing with king attic and
everything else but it's just the way
people conduct themselves you just don't
don't do the personal attacks
and then yeah it's always that and it's
also like
i think the the the like immediate
access of twitter makes everyone feel
like they have the right to like voice
their opinion and everybody else
but like at a certain point when you
when you get to like
a certain level of kind of whatever
public platform followers whatever you
want to call it
um you can't just be like like you can't
sanely listen to every single person who
wants to
hear like nobody has the right to get
their voice to you to say stuff to you
to whatever
so yeah i mean you pretty much have to
use block especially when you're
a reporter who's like reporting negative
things and antagonistic things about
companies
and is going to piss off a bunch of
fanboys as a result
um i would say like the large majority
of people i've watched on twitter
are are console fanboys with like the
xbox and playstation and [ __ ] in there
a huge chunk is gamer gators like if
anyone's a gamer gator i'm gonna block
them immediately
because those people just do not get any
of my time or bandwidth or attention
fair enough look it's your platform you
have the right to run it the way you
choose it i'm glad we
cleared the air on the twitter aspect
because i just thought it was
pretty hilarious exactly so we're going
to get into this um i don't know where
the co-host with the co-most is but uh
so
um anything came in real quick before i
jump in um
yeah we have uh we have a couple of of
super chats and then there's a regular
chat that i want to read out sure
um we have flame with the two dollar
super chat the lords are on the o
oled today welcome jason so we're
looking very crispy at 4k 120 on the
oled very nice
then we have michael aka best sides
finest five dollar super chat
well well well lords what have we
here oh the trash station oh they
started the fanboys
seriously the playstation is trash god
bless say less oh my god
wow this is what i'm talking about but
see lisa
listen jason you you can't be upset when
he's talking truth
oh stop
it's not even that you know what it is
is the fact that i pay 500
and it hasn't showed me it's worth any
time you go to some place and you pay x
amount of dollars you have x amount of
expectations right
and literally my joint is collecting
dust but i know
in june i don't care what anybody say i
know in june
the real launch party starts there where
rancher the clay hits the deck
and myself is locked up on that
television
clank from beginning to end and i know
what i'm getting then but right now yeah
it's been an absolute waste of my money
but
oh my oh my goodness consoles are always
like that
no no my xbox has been really good from
day one oh my
messy idiot one more thing i want to
read uh this
is this is lord paris is in the chat and
i wanted to read this out because there
was an
exchange a while back that uh i guess
he's clarifying okay
so from paris i'm here because jason and
i had a miscommunication no hard
feelings
[ __ ] happens but he was right and
mistook what i said at the time
wow so paris i remember this
jason i remember this exchange and it
goes back to what
we say about how exchanges start
sometimes sometimes
we perceive people's the tone of voice
and what they say right and what they
say on twitter and it's very hard to
sort of express yourself
kind of properly sometimes on twitter
right yeah and it seems like that
exchange between you guys
got it it was strong opinions on either
side and it got heated in a way that
felt like
it was sort of like well this crossed
the line is that how you felt about that
exchange jason yeah
yeah paris paris we should shop
privately
yeah this is what i this is what i love
to see
but yeah i think from what i remember
that
started because paris said i in an
agenda an agenda is a very loaded word
when it comes to reportering and
yeah i mean we don't need to rehash it
parents let's chat privately happy to to
settle things and clear the air
because they're fantastic i mean we have
a lot of mutual friends and they all say
you're a good dude so i appreciate it
chat
yeah yeah i want to put up i'll put a
shout out for my man hold law if there's
any way that that could be fixed
i like gold yeah again just just this
way to sit which is where the spirit of
forgiving
oh my god yeah i mean so so something i
should say i don't know if a lot of
people know this but like
i get i've gotten a lot of emails over
the years from people who are like hey
like i sent you a nasty message on
twitter you blocked me i'm sorry about
it can you unblock me and
every single time i will always unbox
them like wow i believe in general like
this it's not because i'm like an
amazing person or anything but like i
believe that everyone deserves to grow
and
change and like everyone can make
mistakes and apologize for them like
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that and like like who who among us
hasn't has a bad day and like said
something
you know what's crazy though jason see
that what you said right there
most people assume that doesn't happen
yeah i think because it's more private
right right and then so the discourse
online is that there's this hatred
between the you know you
and however many people whatever and who
knows how many of those relationships
have been amended over there over time
exactly
but it's weird because again because of
your sort of stature in the gaming
industry people
sort of take that as oh and i'm
generalizing here but sometimes people
say
you know fighting with people on the
internet over video game stuff
is the way to go right right and i think
here
i think here we've sort of made it a
point to say no we need to have
conversations
even with people that we disagree with
yeah that's why i like this podcast
you guys are appreciative i appreciate
it i appreciate it big time it means a
lot to us thank you so much for that
jason let's get
into it cause we got a lot of stuff and
time so you know we
had what what's up kids one more real
quick stitch dollar super chat where is
the trucker today aka
we're looking for him we're putting
people out let us know
let us know if you see that anyway so
you
we would have had the four horsepower
gaming what is missing shout out to
addict i hope he's okay sir all jokes
aside
usually sometimes it's the power issue
he may have to work or hopefully he just
wasn't playing games
late and overslept seven a.m yeah yeah
so hopefully it's not that but uh let's
get the rest of the lords in around with
these updated
five-minute time-sensitive intros
because jason is here in limited time
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patreon of the iron
bank
mommy lord sob how we doing sir i am
doing fantastic today doing very well
as you well know i've i found some ways
to to the game a little bit more during
the course of the week and i'll leave it
at that yeah i'll just leave it at that
shout out to the series shout out to
little man
um so uh i've been able to sort of mess
around with some stuff during the week i
haven't had a chance to play uh
the mass effect legendary edition yet
but from all i hear the you know mass
effect 1 is still as great as it always
has been
is it i'm going to refrain from it's
been no change
there's been no changes whatsoever it
was always perfect oh
god i could continue oh and beyond that
you know what's funny i also threw on
the the much maligned assassin's creed
unity
because it has fps boost it has auto hdr
now
wow it was funny to see a game that sort
of
broke ubisoft for a while yeah um sort
of come back and look and run like that
on a console
who did that for you yeah yeah yeah
j-rom
j-ron um
and that's pretty much it i played a
little bit more of a village but i
haven't had a chance to dive deep but
i'm enjoying what i've seen so far
okay um excited to do more of that no
doubt no doubt
and of course we have who i just saw
yesterday the incredible hulk of this
aka
the access gamer ooh the prophet
of xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
ooh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
i'm doing fantastic fresh off the
collectors barbecue aka the big d
shelf barbecue oh my god we had
so many people out there first i want to
give a shout out to cognito for coming
through
thank you for fighting me that was fun
that was funny i felt seven years old
yeah i got i got to give a shout out to
atm for um
attempt for uh hosting it his his
collection is beautiful um
car got a chance to go downstairs and
check his collection oh my god
brother it was amazing that was like a
museum of college
yeah like an x-men like this
arcade co-op i mean a coin-op upright
x-men oh
that he built himself wow um because me
and him was talking in the background on
how to build it
everything was custom-made from that
that that cabinet that he did
um he's a he's a true uh pillar of our
community yes
everybody was there shout out to my uh
salmon burgers being burped
sorry for the non-meat lovers i know
yeah but but i did get my
my regular salmon done and everything
but uh they had these special
sauces everybody ribs everybody was
talking you had different segments
talking about
uh comic books uh video game and you
know
shout out for cog to bring in uh the
what would the mass effects uh
controversy there
dude didn't know what they was watching
oh you brought that to the you brought
that to the barbecue
i didn't bring which one was better but
what it is as you can tell these
are it's jason like these guys are
hardcore statue collectors this is great
community
it's my first time meeting a lot of
these guys in person and they're awesome
guys
but people don't realize comics statues
and gaming is so
intertwined and they've been out the
game so long
so we started i started talking about
gaming i'm like wait a minute you guys
didn't know there was a legendary
collection like
are you kidding me so we just try to
help them get back in the game and get
ways
and then he said well you know they did
know about the game
and then oh park they were like we love
too
but i i gotta say i love the fact that
i've seen so many people new people
playing this game
yeah yeah so many so cool beautiful to
see
so um this week i was playing resident
evil 7. nice uh
not village because i'm sick and tired
of buying a new game
but i'm doing it yeah by the time i get
to it it's only worth 20 bucks
so i'm i'm almost finished i'm at the
end okay
i got from the scary stuff to where
resident evil starts to turn into
bizarro stuff like okay that's fun
type of stuff but the game is beautiful
i love the engine
i i love their direction
on it feels like an extension of four
you know with the first person stuff and
you know
it's just it's really good stuff and i
love what they're doing
and i don't ever want them to stop so i
know i'm going to jump straight into
village
right after like okay i'm going to go
buy that
but i still have resident evil 2 remake
to do and
three but um destiny had a huge drop yes
uh shout out to the last word
uh go check that out it was a great uh
episode um
yeah it's uh i'm indifferent about it uh
it's it feels like more rehash with
different people but the the ability to
um change and regurgitate fix it up and
just try to give you something different
try to appease the community
i do appreciate the effort and it did
take me away from outriders and it did
put me in there because you know was
with me on a couple of things and every
five seconds they do something wrong i
said backed out right now
yeah yeah yeah right it's cool i can't
log in too fast
is going up this week i'm doing that
they came in so
did the live unboxing on dcx that was
last week beautiful
check that out um but this is coming up
today all right
no doubt let's get it moving and of
course we have the gaming ninja himself
the shinobi law incognito spreading that
realness in a roman iop not telling what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear i'll keep it quick
shout out to the last word ebonzis we
had d flawless on amazing content
creator absolutely hilarious
if you want to know what's going on in
the new season of dusty please check out
the last word it is up
been playing mass effect legendary
edition like lord jason but getting back
to nostalgia the feels
it you just like wow i forgot how much
of a space opera how epic this thing is
and i'm gonna do the whole trilogy
straight forward man it feels so good at
60 frames plus whoo
it really does it's amazing and the hdr
is it's different
yakuza like a dragon i'm almost there
chapter 12. i'm at the hard boss i'm
trying to get that done
and of course destiny's season of the
splicer
someone oh wow laura fonzarelli welcome
to the runway
never shouted out that is the homie
shout out to jay philip so um
solve we got that done any business and
then let's get into the whole thing we
have uh yeah we have a couple of super
chats so these will be the last ones
that we read
before uh because we got to respect
jason's time so we will get
all super chat by the end of the show um
we have max the lazy otaku with the 10
super chat i know it's been a minute
since i've been here but i gotta head
out cause night work but two things
20 years of xbox and e3 y'all know the
deal plays a clip of king laughing
maliciously
[Laughter]
yes yes then we have scrub nurse with
the five dollars in the chat a glorious
sunday
listening to the lords while driving two
hours away from the home
to copper series x my boy found for me
go get that series action
carrying it with that c10 oled
absolutely
get that c10 going on no doubt then we
have the homie hustling motivate two
dollar super chat
can we get an iop slash triple click
crosstalk
that would be fun we caught up with a
subject and of course we have lord jay
fonz joining the realm so put the
crest in the chat thank you jay fine
great content
creator awesome content one last one
sure eric j with the five dollars
chad what's up fam have a good show
often when dudes get blocked the first
sus thing they say is i didn't say
anything that bad
little angels yeah every time every time
no i'm just trying i just i just called
him a prick like what did i yeah yeah
it's like i
just said his journalism sucked i mean
that's a big deal
it's like paris said the receipts are
out there always yeah they're always out
you say an internet can't come back and
like i said cognito's about the peace
we're just trying to bring yes
but salute dj i feel what you said let's
get into it first of all who just
pulled up in the realm doing overtime
doing logicgaming.net
own daniel may aka gondor's condo how
you doing sir let me make sure your mic
is good
i'm doing great uh it is an honor to be
here
i got blood sweat and pixels on my left
press reset on my right
i'm raging oh he's ready
i liked your piece i enjoyed your piece
thank you oh you got blessed by the
legend
[Laughter]
that is an awesome feeling man so let's
get into it man so obviously we got into
what the lord's been playing
but we gotta focus on lord jason his
latest book
press reset and of course a deeper diver
into the culture of game development
with some questions but before i start
that i wanted to ask you lord jason i
know it's been a year since you've been
here well iop 146 i believe
you at the time you were the news editor
kotaku um i want to know just quickly
how is that transition now at bloomberg
like do you feel settled in
what has changed in your in your role
it's wild because i started the new job
in the middle of the pandemic so i still
haven't actually been to the office i've
been working from home
since i started which has been wild yeah
no it's cool it's
it's a very different audience in a very
different world so i've been like
learning a ton of stuff which is part of
why i took the job is because like i
wanted some
something totally new i didn't want to
just be writing for the gaming audience
and like doing gaming blogging like i
was in kotaku
i was there for like eight years so i
wanted something completely different
and yeah it's been great i've been
learning a
ton of stuff from editors and bloomberg
and in the newsroom there it's like a
humongous newsroom
doing lots of stuff with them like radio
and tv stuff at bloomberg and yeah it's
been really cool it's been it's been
good stuff
nice man good to see you continuing on
doing what you love and the elevation is
respected
good to see another thing i want to ask
you on what i love about your first book
i think we're gonna get into the new
stuff but um
it's how you like unable to unearth
these like amazing stories and um
especially with the conditions how games
are made i don't mean you talked offline
about destiny but especially the destiny
origin story with bungie that whole
thing
and um you know just basically this
weird hodgepodge
comes together last minute but i wanted
to ask you this like
how proud of you are reporting stories
like this
and then the second part is like how do
you go about earning the trust of these
devs to tell you these very
personal stories about game development
yeah um
yeah i i definitely like i in general as
my career has gone on
i way prefer telling behind the scenes
stories and like doing stuff that people
find interesting and informative and
that they won't find out anyway as
opposed to like the whole
leaked game and trying to chase like
what's going to be at e3 like that stuff
doesn't really interest me
very much occasionally i'll i'll step
into those waters but like that
is way less interesting to me than like
reporting on stuff that you won't find
out about anyway like it's not
it's not interesting to me to be like
you're going to learn this in a week
it's more interesting to me to be like
i want you to i want to tell these
stories that like won't be out there
regardless and that's what's really cool
about
writing books is you get to do that and
yeah i mean to try to answer your second
question it's hard to tell
um like trust is a funny thing like it's
hard to tell why someone would want to
talk to me why someone would trust me to
tell their story
um but i think a lot of it is just doing
the work and like continually
like doing having a lot of conversations
with people and just like writing
stories
and just like having this body of work
that shows to people that hey i will do
my best to like
to to do a service to you to like to
tell your story in a fair
accurate respectful way and yeah i mean
that's that's i
i i try to do that and and hopefully i
pulled it off i'm sure to some people i
haven't pulled it off
um yeah but this is probably therapeutic
to be honest with you
definitely it's good people yeah i i get
on the phone with someone and they're
like this is like therapy
exactly they don't have to see you all
the time
um so they won't say anything to friends
and stuff like that you know
fear of judgment or whatever but they
get a chance to talk to you
and you're like and he's gonna like hear
the story
not judge the story before the story is
said and they can talk about crunch or
they can talk about how they're feeling
with uh work conditions and stuff of
this nature
and actually get it across to somebody
that's going to listen
opposed to not you know just not
judge you know it's it's it's you you
get judged a lot
before you actually hear the whole story
in the head to talk to someone
who's actually just really there to just
listen to you i think that goes a long
way and i think they understand that so
that's why they're able to talk to you
yeah i agree
yeah i think people also appreciate that
i'm never going to run a story just
based on one person's account
and so i'm always going to talk to
multiple people and so i think people
appreciate that because they know i mean
first of all if they don't want to be
identified for a story they know that
i'll protect their identity
but second of all like i think it can be
like a thorough
a more thorough account when it's like
okay i heard from all of these different
people
yeah and um like i did that with with my
books and
and as much as possible when i'm doing
kind of long-form investigative pieces
it's just trying to talk to as many
people as possible to make sure that the
story is as thorough as it can be
no i'm not fair if i forgot real quick
do you have that
at bloomberg is that do you have that
type of autonomy like basically
do what you like are passionate about or
do you have sort of directives as well
beyond that yeah i mean it's different
because it's like
when i do stories there has to be the
stories of bloomberg would publish are
very different
there's like a very different bar than
what kotaku would publish it could
because taco i could be like
um i could just publish any story that
would be interesting to the gaming crowd
but with bloomberg it's like this has to
be
interesting to our our readership which
is a lot broader like the business
people and bankers and investment people
and mainstream audiences who read
bloomberg
um are very different than like your
gaming audience so
um if something is just about like like
a specific like one small slice of
gaming culture it might not be as
interesting to them
to my editors unless i can find some way
to like encapsulate bigger themes and
bigger picture stuff so
there's a lot of conversations with my
editors about like what is
what makes a good story here what makes
a story that's appropriate for bloomberg
et cetera et cetera it's been a really
interesting challenge like there's stuff
that i pitched that
i think would have worked well at kotaku
but doesn't necessarily work well with
bloomberg yeah
um because this is bigger fish that
you're frying
right it's not the same stuff and i'm
saying that kotaku was a small fish by
any means
what i'm what i'm talking about is you
like you indicated you have to look uh
at a broader spec right so now
is it uh going higher up the chain to
talk to
uh ceos and stuff like that opposed to
talking lower down the chain ceos will
never talk
to me
because you do great work so you never
know let me let me give you an example
well i mean there i think a lot of them
just wouldn't want to answer my
questions because i would ask you go ask
them questions
let me give you an example so i i
published a story a few weeks ago about
playstation
and like their broader bigger picture
stuff at playstation
that sorry story started that story
started
by me um looking into vasg
and like the the sony san diego studio
that had been rumored for a while and
and how they were everyone thought they
were making an uncharted game and i
found out what they were actually doing
a lot of us remake and like
started diving into that and that was
the original version of the story was
like what's going on at this studio
but that is the type of thing where it's
like the bloomberg people would be like
why would anyone care about that
right um that like and i'm like well a
lot of people like thought
that they were doing uncharted and there
were rumors and they're just like no it
needs to be bigger picture so i
zoomed out and like incorporated a lot
other of other like
playstation stuff um into that and so it
became like a larger
like zoom out at the organization so
there's a lot of just like
zooming out and looking at the big
picture that's what i'm talking about as
opposed to
like like interviewing higher people
which
hasn't really i mean we have people who
interview ceos and talk to
them around fiscal quarters and stuff
but um but yeah
i do have the autonomy to just kind of
do pursue whatever stories i want which
is really great
which i very much appreciate yeah that's
awesome i got two quick ones and then
i'm gonna open it up i know
lord daniel may's got some great
questions we'll get him to get his in as
well
um i want to play devil's advocate you
want to be on the flip side
i clearly have no problem with your
reporting right but some friends of mine
have said they argue with me they say
lord jason you know
crunch is normal you know that's a part
of the business and then the second part
is they say
i think he nitpicks i think he picks and
chooses only
disgruntled people and and it's not it's
not balanced so how do you answer
these people in regards to crunch as a
normal part of the game and as far as
the the people you choose for actually
interviewing for these great stories
that you you end up
putting out so i mean first of all
crunch is absolutely a normal part of
the games industry and that's kind of a
problem don't you think
like i think that like maybe people
think that the crunch
means something um means just like
working overtime and it's just like oh i
work my overtime at my job and it sucks
but i do it but like the biggest
difference in the games industry is
first of all it's usually not paid
because people are on salaries
they're working office jobs where you're
like putting in all these hours and
you're not getting paid for it second of
all it lasts for months it's not like
like oh a couple weeks to finish the
game it could be like months and months
of
overtime on end third of all like if
you're working
if you're doing that too then that sucks
and your job should be called out as
well
but anyway that's all besides by the way
my new book press reset is actually
totally not about crunch it's about
volatility in the games industry which i
think is a way bigger problem
but um to answer your second question
about uh
disgruntled employees yes that is
something i'm very cognizant of and yes
absolutely like people are disgruntled
are way more likely to talk to a
reporter
but i always try to talk to people who
aren't disgruntled and in fact
um i heard a couple weeks ago um
because there was some like drama around
three four three and a half infinite
developers
i heard from someone someone reached out
to me and was like hey i want to talk to
you i've actually had a good time
working on halo for this reason and this
reason and i was like great i want to
hear your perspective like i want to
hear as many perspectives as possible
that's always my job and oftentimes i
will actively seek out people who are
not disgruntled and who i know are not
disgruntled because
i want to make sure that i'm not just
getting exaggerated versions of the
story and like
that's that's part of my job like i said
before i'm trying to talk to as many
people as possible
in order to make sure that it's like a
fair account and
and that i'm getting like the a thorough
the thorough truth of
what's happening so yeah i mean it's
it's this is not
something it's something that a lot of
reporters have to deal with is like
having to filter out
what's just gossip and bitching about
your job just complaining about your job
trying to avoid cursing complaining
about your job and what's
and what's like a real problem and i
mean the amount
of stuff that uh that i
have heard and not reported i think
would really
shock people because oftentimes it's
like oh my job did
my my boss did blah blah blah and it's
like like there's a lot of stuff that's
just like personal complaints that
wouldn't go into a story and part of my
job is to like filter out what
what is like the bigger picture here
what is the real story here
so yeah i mean it's a way more difficult
i think people just kind of like uh
people who don't do journalism just kind
of assume that it's like
oh well this guy uh uh some
some worker who was disgruntled like
went and complained to him and then he
just turned it into an article but it's
so much
more complicated
these stories is a lot i like the fact
that you gather
uh a whole bunch of stories and then you
can
you can actually follow a common thread
when you hear multiple people talk and
they can give different accounts of this
instance so you can really get down to
the truth because
uh you know um people will always say
something from their perspective to make
their self look good
and then if you hear multiple accounts
of it you can actually get to the middle
part where the truth is lying right in
between
and i do love and respect the fact that
that's what you do you don't go off of
one of something you actually go off of
multiple accounts of a situation
and you don't probably rush the story
you probably wait until actually you can
get
all of the story to actually uh you know
find
the truth that lies in between yeah it's
it's why i was
frustrated a couple weeks ago when king
your xbox army uh decided to
because uh because uh because i had
tweeted about this three four three guys
i was gonna talk about that
three yeah yeah and and he he then
walked back his
comments or at least said they were
taken out of context or whatever but
everything he said in his original
message the whatever i saw and reset her
the translator version of his message
all of that
was 100 true because i had been hearing
the same things from
like almost a dozen probably more than a
dozen
other people who have worked at 343
because i've been working i mean i've
not
made it a secret that i've been very
curious about halo infinite absolutely
i've been talking to a lot of people who
worked on the game
and everything you said about like the
tools being in
in progress and um the vision constantly
changing that is all a hundred percent
true um it's also often true
in multiple gay like in in broad
in the broader context it's true of many
if not all aaa games
which is why i talked to tweeted about
that in the first place and then
yeah suddenly like i have hundreds of
people tweeting at me about how my story
is was taken out of my story is wrong
and i should fix my story and i'm like
what are you talking about i didn't
write a story
i just tweeted this because i know it's
true right and it remains true
and yeah yeah the these [ __ ] family
i'm sorry
please stand down
when it comes to something that's that
they have hopes on because
a lot of these dudes bet on these horses
and they expect these horses to win and
eat
they put all the eggs in one barrel and
and then
and when you're like oh halo infinite is
and they don't want to hear anything
wrong
with their picture they always want to
hear a rosy outlook to it and that's not
exactly how it goes
and we all understand where it is and
where we hope it to be
right now not everything is going to
follow that same path but to tweet at
you
and and harass you that that is not you
will
never catch anything you know like from
me bothering anybody about something
[Music]
it's funny because it's like uh yeah
it's it's um
i read it though and i was like oh that
sounds like it's really true
and i really in my head you know
what you wrote like not being there not
knowing it
i'm like yeah that sounds really true
and i'm like please get it together you
got a couple more months to get it
together
get it together yeah what's something
that you that you
read like a tweet that you read in
response to that
that wasn't disrespectful that was
accurate
but actually uh married what you
what you tweeted like you understand
what i'm saying like did somebody have
some
type of information that kind of
coincided with what you tweeted
yeah i mean i i've been hearing this
stuff privately i've been talking to
people who've worked on halo for
years now because people have been
telling me like behind the scenes
there's some problems here
blah blah blah 343 has some issues one
of the biggest issues i've talked about
this before but one of the biggest
issues super three has is like
an over reliance on contractors and then
they have a term limit for contractors
and so a lot of people wind up leaving
um because they they uh their 18 months
are up or whatever it is
and you lose all that experience and you
lose all the talent and suddenly
you you have you're in this position
where you have to be replacing all these
people and it's all just a mess
um that's that's one example of like the
problems that are happening in 343 but
but one day i'll write an article about
it at some point and and
i have no idea when we'll we'll see but
um but to your point earlier by the way
about like people just
just wanting yeah people just killing
the messenger for delivering bad news
it happens every single time and like i
always see this
this uh there's this like belief in like
positivity and i actually think that can
be super toxic because
positivity and just like wanting
non-stop like hey we're on the same side
here
like hey gamers we do it all for you
that can be used to mask a lot of the
real problems that are happening in a
lot of the abuses that are happening
so last year i was reporting a lot on cd
projekt and cyberpunk
and the tone suddenly changed um
like after the game came out because
like when i was reporting well you were
getting
killed when you were reporting i
remember you were printing on some of
the issues they were having the crunch
and so on and so on
and yeah it's just like people go after
me because they don't want to believe
that their precious cd projekt
would do anything wrong and then
suddenly cyberpunk comes out and it's
bad and suddenly
i'm getting a million messages a day
from probably the same people being like
investigate cyberpunk what happened here
both ways they can't they
it's the same thing with halo it's just
like people are looking for like
i i think that like a lot of gamers just
to play too much phoenix right and so
they believe that like
they can find a contradiction in
everything that's said on the internet
and like
if they find the right evidence they'll
be able to they like think his life
that life is like a video game and so
when i
tweet something that is like yeah this
is exactly what i've heard
and the guy comes out and and walks it
back and and says it was taken out of
context and
that he doesn't want it anymore um then
there's like suddenly
hundreds of people are like oh it
couldn't have been true
people don't think twice about like i
wonder why a former employee of a
company who said something that got that
blew up all over the internet something
that was
interpreted as negative i wonder why
like
that and i feel bad for that guy like
he's his comments i've been talking to
him i haven't heard from him or anything
but
i i do plan on reaching out to him at
some point but like
his his comments got blown up all over
the internet i feel terrible about that
but
but um to to for people to blame me
for sharing it and saying i have heard
the same thing
from multiple positions
and people people were acting the most
insane thing about that whole scenario
was people
the number of messages i got from people
saying hey you should fix the article
and be like hey i didn't freaking you
didn't make an article
i would not be writing an article about
what one person said
i would be writing an article about what
many people said i would not be writing
an article about this one guy without
reaching out to him and talking to him
myself first
or at the very least getting my own
translation what i did was tweeted it
and said
this sounds like every other triple a
video game which is true
it really drove me nuts the the way i
was a hot one i'm glad we addressed that
because you know what's
you know what's funny it's it's this
because this is that's a journalist
people
okay he's a journalist i'm a provocateur
[Laughter]
oh
and i will tweet something about
something i heard from somebody
you will gather sources because he went
to school
he put in the work he did all of that
stuff
he is a journalist
somebody told me the other day like oh i
look to you to be a journalist
excuse you oh yeah yeah yeah
you look someplace else out of your mind
i'm glad i'm glad we clarified that i'm
so cause i did want to talk about that
it was a hot button
yeah i just saw someone in the chat
saying that this person reached out to
me that is
again not true this person did not the
guy who
the concept artist did not reach out to
me i imagine he reached out to people
who
actually wrote articles about this not
the guy who tweeted saying
this sounds like what i've heard and
what the rest of the chip played it's
just nuts to me like how many people
just like
believe these complete misinformation
often it makes me wonder if just like
social media and the internet was just a
massive mistake and that like we should
not human beings are not meant to be
this disconnected i agree with the
mistake part completely i know
i'm agreeing because doesn't use social
media yes it is it's how it's used
this is another discussion but i do
understand the points that
there's a nastiness to it but then
there's sometimes where it's positive
where awareness is brought to a
situation
that a lot of people didn't know and
let's be real you know what i'm saying
especially i i look at you know what
happened you know not to get too
political here but you know with george
floyd like could you imagine in the era
of non-social media and non-camera
phones think about how many atrocities
that were not recorded so it's it's a
balance it's good to it and it's bad to
about i want to move on
we've got a lot of stuff to ask you and
lord yeah let's see let's get it i'm
going to talk about the new no dan
you're up after this what last question
there and i got you because i know
you've been patient
um okay we gotta get it to the noodle so
like so i've said what we're here for
press reset ruin and recovery in the
video games industry
now one theme i see a lot through this
book to me is just the pure
volatility of the games industry right
and
i got to be honest with jay's on a
corporate level and
on a development level this book really
hit home for me emotionally
chapter 6 38 studios
because as a sports fan i'm not i wasn't
boston red sox but i remember kurt
schillings off we know the famous series
i know you know you're a yankee fan you
know like
the bloody socks was like an iconic
thing you know
i love your choice of the title the
story the whole bit the reason why it
hit so hard for me king is like
if i just had a little bit of game
development tablet and i was looking
you know it would have been food i would
have i would have applied for this
it felt like the dream job y'all yeah
like was he
really to his credit you got this big
megastar mlb i'm not going to spoil it
too much because i want people to read
the book
but you know this big mlb star who's
just like
tons of capital looks like for all
intents and purposes
treating the you know game of game dev
well and
almost over tweeting them well they got
to pull back a little bit right jason
and then
you know just to see what happened
and and i was just like wow how this
thing
fell to pieces and then also one last
point
got a second lease on life during a lot
during the tragedy financially so i want
to ask you this lord jason like
to me this is a pretty heartbreaking
story like this one almost i was like
damn this would have been me i would
have got caught out there
you know what i mean so like could you
can you say how it was putting this
together the story together of kingdoms
of alamo
slash copernicus like how was that for
you
reporting that story yeah it's tough
this whole book was
was tough um having these conversations
with people about like some of the
hardest times in their lives
um although i think that like a large uh
uh
chunk of it was also talking about like
how they recovered afterwards which was
pretty cool because they're a lot of
like cool recovery stories
and also a lot of stories about just
like here's how things can get better
but yeah with 38 it was wild because
it's a lot of people who
didn't just get like screwed over and
then they moved somewhere for this job
that
that that fell apart it's also they got
robbed of their final paycheck because
they didn't get paid
um their last check they didn't get
severance they got
stranded in rhode island where there are
no other video game jobs some of them
like
did not have money um and then what
really is just like
man unbelievable is that for a few of
them what happened was they moved from
massachusetts to rhode island
and a few of them so the company said
hey if you can't sell your house as part
of our relocation program
we'll take over the mortgage for your
house and try to sell it ourselves and
pay your mortgage
until until we can sell it and so
a few people i think it was seven or six
um
their houses didn't sell so they gave
them to the company the company took
over the mortgages and then they went
and got apartments in rhode island or
whatever
houses whatever they did um when the
company exploded
suddenly those mortgages reverted back
to the original owners somewhere in the
fine print it said like that
this is what happens right so suddenly
you have six people seven people who
a don't have a job anymore b have rent
in rhode island
c still have a mortgage in messaging and
it's like oh my god this is like
heartbreaking like i can't even imagine
what this is like and it's no wonder so
many people like leave the video game
industry if you can get stuck in
situations like this
the number it's just constant layoffs
and shutdowns and
it just feels like a very unstable job
and a very unstable career and
and that's why you see like so many
vacancies for senior level talent
across game studios like if you ever go
to a game studio website
um look up their jobs and you'll see
senior that senior that senior this it's
because people don't stay in games for
longer than like
five six seven years it'll just burn out
people are just like man i can't do this
i can't keep
moving around the country every every um
yeah two years every time i get laid off
and that's what the book is about and
the book says hey this is unsustainable
we gotta fix this let's find some ways
to do it let's tell some stories about
what happened to people
how they were covered and let's find
some solutions no i'm glad
you bought excuse me glad you bought it
to light because you know i'm in this
part of my career while i'm
possibly you know transitioning thinking
about i was i mean i am thinking about
the industry on some level you know and
you know this really puts things in
perspective with certain aspects
you know and i really have to do due
diligence and
if i'm if i am to pursue that so this
one really hit home for me
it was like that was probably one of the
closest i came to tears because some of
the stories were just
really tough but yeah yeah i thought i
knew the story until like
yeah yeah i think the scariest part
about this is that when you
you go through all the stories of the
book the thing the through line that you
see is that it doesn't matter
if you're this super well renowned
auteur in the gaming industry
if you're if you've been around forever
and you're super well respected
it'll still chew you up and spit you out
so imagine someone just coming in out of
college
imagine someone just getting into the
industry for the first time like you
might be doing cog
it's a scary thing where it doesn't
discriminate
yeah it doesn't matter i mean you can
leave one situation thinking
i mean in his book he's even had
scenarios where a person leaves one
situation thinking it's going to be
a sinking ship to thinking that
something's more promising and then the
same outcome happens
when they move but enough about that
because i want to get lord daniel man
lord gondor's condor lord that man what
what you got for lord jason you've been
patient brother
thank uh no yeah thank you um i think
the first thing i really want to ask is
actually
the first chapter and you're talking
about warren spector
and specifically his time with epic
mickey but
you also mentioned that he started his
career in i think 1981
so he spent like decades throughout the
gaming industry
so how did like the culture of crunch
in the gaming industry change throughout
spectre's career
yeah he's one of the elder statesman one
of the one of the legendary designers
obviously warren spector
he was the director of system shock and
ultimate underworld and deus ex
um or not director of all those games
but how to how to hand produce
all those games um yeah i mean as far as
crunch
crunch has definitely changed a lot over
the years
um in that it used to be more of like
like uh the games industry used to be a
little more like fra
frat like where it's like a bunch of
people like living in a house like
drinking diet coke and eating pizza and
stuff
and then it's gotten a little more
professionalized and now the culture
cultures of crunch are more like
now we're staying in an office and
ordering chinese food and
those big platters and that's our crunch
dinner no but but
the the reason that i started the book
with that story is hey because i think
it's a really fascinating story and more
inspector is a fascinating life
but b because i think that that
spectre's journey kind of proves that
even if you're like one of the most
respected like talented game developers
of all time someone who's a legend in
this industry
you still can't find stability and that
to me is so sad
the fact that like even someone like
warren spector like warren friggin
spectre
directed deus ex is like such a
revolutionary game i i know that
some people out there might be a little
young and and and didn't play the
original but but this game like changed
a lot and
warren spectre's work just in the
immersive sim world has
inspired everything from like bioshock
to fallout to
breath of the wild like anything you've
played has probably been been inspired
by
by warren spektor's stuff in some way
and the fact that he has been
like moving from job to job and just
unable to find a
sustainable like long-term career is
just so sad and
it kind of is reflective of the entire
video game industry and and the problems
that it has just keeping on to people
and like
like keeping people just like healthy
and happy and employed stably
it's really sad yeah yeah absolutely
louis
vuitton i know you got another one so
i'm gonna let you double up you've been
super pissed
thanks um yeah so then after uh
you finished telling uh spector's story
you move into
probably like what i thought was the
cornerstone
uh story of this book with irrational
games because
you then see references of the sort to
irrational games throughout the rest of
the book like you see it in the molasses
project
you see it with the disappearance of 2k
marin as you call it so how much did
you intentionally plan for irrational
games to
be connected to the rest of the book
yeah well so what happened was when i
was reporting i knew i wanted to cover a
rational i knew that
that that was one of the going to be the
big one of the big studios i wanted to
cover because
it's so interesting and such a a strange
situation because they had just released
a successful game in bioshock infinite
before they shut down a year later and
it's just like how can this happen
because usually you think oh a studio's
shutting down they must have released
some bad game that flopped and said they
ran out of money or something but
that obviously did not happen in this
case and then from there i found
a group of people who had left to go
indie and focus on them because i found
them really interesting
and then found and then learned about
bioshock 2's development which kind of
sprung from a rational
so a lot of the stuff just that i that i
reported and learned
kind of just fell from there like like
came out through the reporting process
um after i learned about irrational and
after i like i
i drove up to boston and did a bunch of
interviews with folks over there
um which led me down some roads and
that's often what happens in reporting
um for anyone out there who's interested
in just the behind the scenes of
journalism is usually you're like
talking to one person and you say hey
who else should i talk to and
they'll say well i'll talk to this
person and this person and this person
and
it can lead you down some really
interesting roads as long as you're just
willing to talk to as many people as
possible which
which is my favorite part of the job so
i'm always willing to do that yeah
that's awesome that's awesome and um
i was going to say oh shout out to lord
addict who is glad to make it lord
[Laughter]
look man i've been here this whole time
i know i apologize for missing you yeah
bye bad but glad you could make it
regardless of razzing you a bit but i
want to open it up to uh
softke if they had a question before we
get addict back in
um yeah one one question that i have for
you jason is um
when you look at the when you explore
certain possible solutions
uh to sort of end the volatility or
at least uh lessen it somewhat is
is there thinking on your practice when
i when i i've i've argued a lot on the
podcast that
modern day gaming uh especially aaa
gaming or in any
any any aspect of creating a game
is so tightly wound and so tightly
sort of uh connected to the money aspect
of it that the art
is the art is always going to suffer is
there
are we too far gone to to have an
industry where the creatives take
control again and remove themselves and
remove themselves from
from big business in that regard and
sort of
by proxy sort of eliminate
a lot of the problems that come along
with big business are we too far gone
for that
um or is there is there a pro is there a
way towards getting that because
that is kind of like the nirvana
situation where the art takes precedence
over everything else
and then because as artists you care
about
how each other how how how everybody in
the industry sort of
achieves that art and you know i
obviously the money is is so like i said
it's so tightly wound to that
that it feels like it's unattainable but
it just feels like with stories that you
tell
and the things you hear throughout the
industry it seems like secretly
everybody wants that or it's or
quietly everybody wants that it's just
difficult to remove themselves from that
yeah i mean what you're describing is
the indie world and there's so much good
stuff out there
and there's so many i mean even in this
in press reset a lot of folks who
who get laid off wind up going indy and
having that creative control and being
super happy about it and
it's riskier obviously to go down that
route but like that's where you see a
lot of the most creative interesting
stuff
and like some of my favorite games in
the past couple of years are just these
extrav like exp spectacular indie games
like uh
outer wilds and like return to the
oberthen and a few more like there's so
much good stuff
yeah you love that out of wilds is my
favorite video game thank you dan you
and i are here dan
like hades hades last year and so i
think that
that in the triple a industry i mean
we're talking about like because
graphical fidelity has gone so high up
games are so much more expensive to make
than they were even 10 years ago even
like in the mass effect days right
speaking of mass effect um which i think
a couple of us are playing
and so i think that like as that
graphical fidelity goes up in the x and
the prices go exponentially up and the
game costs
100 million dollars or more um then of
course it's only going to be the biggest
companies that can afford to make those
games and of course they're not
going to take any risks because they
need to see return on that investment if
you're going to put
100 million dollars into something then
of course it has to be open world
like action adventure skill trees level
ups like
dialogue branching down like your house
like hit that freaking checklist
yeah and then and then like add some
micro transactions in there to make sure
that you're getting your money's worth
yeah
and so yeah of course there's no wonder
that that's that's happening
um even with that you still see some
cool creative stuff i mean
right like uh nintendo is putting out
every single year some of the most
interesting like artistic games
and they're a pretty big company that is
definitely concerned about money
i don't think they've discounted any of
their games since like the
the the bush administration but um
it's there's there's always going to be
that line and like
there's never going to be unless someone
wins the lottery or something there's
never gonna be a triple a game that is
entirely artistic driven because
the amount of money at stake is just too
high um
so yeah i mean unless we see like a
world where
gamer's expectation for like graphics
goes down
um that's always good i think that's
happening now yeah
what have you seen i mean i think that's
happening
yeah but even that is like it could
games can be so expensive if you
once you if you expect like a certain
level but
what i've noticed like with uh engineers
and stuff
they're finding ways to lower that bar
i mean to give you that same fidelity
like you know with machine learning and
stuff like that and the ai
uh you know uh interlacing they have
they're trying to lower the bar of the
resolution and all this other stuff
but give you the same fidelity but also
get back to where we was at
like 60 frames a second and an artistic
vision that everybody
once done we all want the artist to be
in total control you don't really want
that
oh yeah yeah you see that you see what
happens with like irrational games it's
one of those things where it's like
you need artists that have business
know-how but are cognizant of the
realities of of a developer and
care about that as opposed to like you
know the big company that's like we just
care about money
right but there's always it's always
chains of command there's
always correct somebody that is uh
controlling like the manager
and the producer everybody is somebody
has to
oversee the artist because if you allow
the artist to get too crazy
you know you you get full kojima stuff
really goes crazy
so
and the thing is what i realized it's
it's so many things that go into this
pot of
making a game and then making it
successful and then you have the
financial and the corporate types who
i'll be honest in the beginning i was
very biased against
because i'm like let the developer do
what he wants to do like the vision
but then like jason i've heard you on
multiple podcasts
where it's like you know sometimes i'm
like yo this game did five million
that's a success but it's like
what was the budget what what what did
they allocate what was their expectation
to reach and if they didn't reach that
they said they spent this exorbitant
amount of money and they didn't reach
that expectation
then yeah to them it's not a success
even though i may
love it like days gone are you talking
about cyberpunk because that was so
funny the other day
i got man again twitter is just the
worst place in the world i i tweeted
about like
i was i was tweeting this article i
wrote about cyberpunk and how the
executives are walking away with these
massive bonuses despite the fact that
they released this flop of a game
and everyone's like cyberpunk's not a
flop cyberpunk is not a flop oh my god
how could you call cyberpunk's flop
like first of all way to focus on what
really matters here
right it's a flop it sold 13 million
copies which seems
amazing until you realize that their
expectations were much higher
because they only released one game
every five years and so they needed it
to sell
like however many copies i think 16
million what was it was
what analysts hoped for in the first
month and then numbers went
way downhill because it was removed from
the playstation store so yes it was a
flop even though it sold 13 million
copies like learn what
friggin math is right yeah i mean
perspective is everything right
perspective is everything and i felt
that from the moment
it got pulled off the playstation store
they should have just stayed quiet
they you know i on a few occasions they
came out and touted
you know what they thought were positive
numbers about it i'm just like shut up
just shut up and get and get yeah they
have to in fairness they have to address
investors
they have to go on earnings correct
there's certain legal obligations that
they have
let me ask you this quick this is a side
note and then i'll get back to attic and
lord daniel
seventy dollar games
yeah internal man 70 bucks on return
is like wow this is a big thing but i
gotta ask you this because again you
you've been reporting behind the scenes
you're starting to see you know what
what financially these corporations are
expecting and
we we're not gonna act like games are
not expensive but at the same time like
is it something that you feel is
justifiably inevitable or is it
something where it's like
nah you know you you should still be
able to do it at that price because in
fairness
games have not gone up for a while right
yeah
and then but at the same time like two
decades but at the same time as gamers
we get mad
when they be like yo you lacing us with
these microtraxes so if i put on
corporate cog hat for a second right
then i could say well
dammit gamers how we supposed to make
this money back if you don't want us to
raise the price but you don't want micro
transactions and we got to stay the same
yeah yeah i've always felt like games
should have variable
pricing like when a game is like
humongous rpg that cost hundreds of
millions
to make and is just 400 hours or
whatever i feel like that should
probably be
like sold for more money than i don't
know even a return
type game which is hard it's hard to to
just having spent having actually spent
70 bucks on my eternal
it's hard to to feel to me it was hard
to justify that price
i bought it because because uh we
covered it for our podcast but like
like even smaller stuff and and uh
that's like one question
yeah yeah you said it at the camera if
you didn't have to cover it
uh for the podcast would you have
purchased it returnal
um i don't know it's hard to say um
well he didn't have recovery he bought
it because he doesn't have to cover
anything anymore like
when it comes to game coverage like it's
what he wants really no no well we
covered we were doing a triple click uh
episode
okay yeah you did and i should be to be
to be candid we expense it to the
podcast
exactly i mean we we we did that here as
well
you know and it's just you know it was
just a question and after
like you know like a overarching shot
towards the game because
probably one day i would get the game
when it actually falls down to the price
that i feel that i want to pay yes plus
sir
but it's just i i'm just trying you know
like to hear it and i understand
when you said like variable scales of
pricing i know that's like a rabbit hole
to go down
but i do agree with that and that's why
sometimes
i just wait for the price to hit my mark
yeah
which is a good way to go yeah i mean i
feel return is a complicated one because
that game
kind of feels like it should have been
in early access so it's kind of like an
unusual case um but i don't know like
smaller scale
stuff um i feel like can sometimes maybe
sometimes it shouldn't be full price and
maybe
if you're gonna charge 70 for the big
your big games that cost you
tens of millions hundreds of millions to
make then maybe if a game costs you only
i don't know 10 million dollars to make
maybe you could sell it for less than
that but i don't know i mean look
at the end of the day um these companies
are super opaque about their financials
and like
how much they're actually taking and
like really if if they wanted to be
just i don't know if they could get away
with that because like games get get
away with this because gamestop would be
mad but
they should be selling digital copies
for less than physical
the only reason they don't do that is
because retail partners will be pissed
at them but i can see
that happening one day in the future
when it doesn't really matter what
gamestop thinks because gamestop is on
their way out
anyway despite despite the reddit memes
um
but yeah but but i could see like a
company like so especially sony
microsoft nintendo who own their own
stores
and so they don't have to pay any cut
when they're selling their games on
their own stores
they could sell their own games at a
discount and do really well and i think
that would be
that would be useful um for people
because they're saving so much money
a company like sony is making so much
more money when you buy a game digital
than they are when you
buy a physical apples and oranges there
but yeah no pricing is an interesting
thing because it's like
it's it's it seems like the games
industry is making more and more money
every single year the last
that i saw was 180 billion dollars 20
20.
and it's like where's all that money
going because it's not going to the
developers and then you look at
the amount of bonuses somebody brought a
yacht
you got to get addicted uh i just bought
a new plane yeah
exactly wow so real quick on the subject
of monetization there
it is there uh like if you look at the
situation with ubisoft now where
they're they're committed to making more
free to play games is that
is that a positive way to monetize that
at the same time also alleviates some of
the
the industry-wide volatility that you
were talking about in the book
whereas you know if you create it create
a game that requires that much
work on it there's going to be a living
thing that's supposedly going to live
you know for a decade or whatever
more does that sort of alleviate the
volatility or does it also
add to all the other reasons why the
industry has been volatile with the
crunch and stuff like that
i think it can um and i think that like
what you used to see
back in the day was okay we just
finished this game we're paying for
200 people at our studio we don't need
200 people so let's lay off 100 of them
nowadays because there's always going to
be more work to do after a game comes
out there's always going to be like
patches and updates than
games as a service quote unquote
especially with these living games like
the division or whatever other free to
play stuff
i guess the division isn't free to play
whatever free to play ubisoft
yeah that new thing um i think that yes
absolutely it can prevent layoffs um
ubisoft is actually pretty good about
not laying off people in the first place
because
they get a bunch of tax credits for the
number of people they have employed in
montreal
there's always a reason it actually can
be cheaper for them to
to keep people employed than to not like
as long as they're hitting those
thresholds that they need to hit
for the government sweet sweet
government tax credits
that's right 201
shout out to that governor for keeping
keeping people employed
you know sure yeah shout out to quebec
but yeah
i think the diversity of games is a good
thing um i think clearly there's like
enough of an audience out there for
for for every type of game mobile free
to play whatever maybe not facebook
games so much anymore
but like there's clearly that audience
and i think it's smart of ubisoft to do
that i know there are a lot of people
freaking out at the thought that like
you've been stopped oh my god ubisoft is
only going free to play but
it's pretty clear i thought that they're
also making triple a games like
the new assassin's creed is gonna be
probably bigger than all the other ones
combined and
like who knows no who knows it's but but
they're clearly like still in that world
they're making avatar they're making a
star wars game like
they're doing all this stuff in the
future still new far cry and whatever so
i think them also like not putting all
their eggs in the
aaa basket and also trying to do smaller
stuff free to play stuff i actually
think it's a super smart business
decision
and yeah to answer your question i think
it can help people
uh stay uh employed if there's always
stuff to work on so
let's get lord addicted because i know
you got some questions you've been out
lord man you're right man what you got
for jason you know first off i want to
say i apologize
i i like okay look to be fair
for being late for your worries sunday
it's you're allowed to be lazy on
sundays
to be fair to fair i do blame mass
effect oh my god
well i played mass effect like eight or
nine in the morning
i told you one of three things
blazing games power loss or
uh working overtime at the job what a
good thing
i was like at this point i might as well
just stay up for the park
and i ended up going to sleep at like 11
o'clock i had an alarm
but my brother came here to check his
email and his phone was then he took it
he took my phone time on your excuses
your questions for lord jason sir
one of the questions i had is uh you
know relove the book
was there any of these stories that you
started writing that
you know when you're writing it first it
just kept getting worse and worse for
you and you was like
yo there's there's some real issues over
there was there any of the those stories
that surprised even you
writing good question yeah um
so first of all so the way that i that i
approach things just to to nitpick a
little bit here is actually to do
all or most of my reporting first before
i even start writing anything so like
usually i'm having like dozens and
dozens of conversations with people
before i even start writing anything
and then i'll write it all in one like
block a time like a two month block of
time
and then i'll be like okay time to fact
check fill in some blanks like edit
whatever
and then that's the rest of the the
process but yeah no definitely um big
huge games that story in there i think
like i think a lot of people know 38 or
at least know the basics of what
happened to 38 studios
but the big huge game story and
especially since they're the ones who
actually made kingdoms of ammo
that story i think is shocking and like
what happened to them with epic
i won't spoil all the details in case
you people are out there want to read
the book but
that story is is mind-boggling and i
still can't believe
everything that happened there and
highly recommend everyone read that
chapter because it's
it's really wild um but yeah no that
that sort of thing
definitely any of the stories the way
that i kind of
uh talk about it in the book is that
like there are humane
shutdowns and layoffs and then there are
inhumane ones and the humane ones are
like okay
we're shutting on the studio but like
we're gonna find everybody
we're going to try to find everybody
jobs elsewhere in the company bring them
out to a job fair get other companies in
here for a job fair
we're going to give everyone severance
like they can they can
we'll pay them for two months even after
the studio closes so they can
have like a little bit of a runway while
they're looking for other stuff that's
like a humane way to approach this
and then there are cases like 38 studios
like telltale
when the company just straight up runs
out of money and it's so irresponsible
run by such a responsible people
that instead of like shutting down two
months earlier and giving everybody
severance
they just say goodbye see ya we're
shutting down everyone's laid off
nobody's getting paid anymore
and that like to me is inhumane and just
like the most painful
like excruciating like man it's it's
tough
it's really tough and hearing some of
those stories was really tough yeah that
was brutal
i would definitely again very emotional
uh bloody socks i get you again
i tell people get to that man yeah lord
lord daniel let's get you man i know you
yeah man and for all i talk about this
in the book but like
just to hit a point because i know
there's some people out there i don't
know among you guys but i know there are
definitely people out there who are
skeptical of unions
and i think that the thing about a union
is that like
it's not something that can save
everything it's not something that will
cure all the industry's woes
and it's not even going to stop a studio
from shutting down like if a studio runs
out of money it runs out of money
but if you have a union and you have
like a contract that says anyone who's
laid off has to be paid
two months of severance no matter what
or whatever it is right
then if you're the manager of telltale
or 38 studios
instead of like running the company into
the ground trying to find money until
the last possible minute and then
screwing everyone over because you
couldn't find money um
instead you would have to shut down your
company two months earlier and give
everyone two months of severance
which would have been the responsible
thing to do instead of just like holding
out hope
for like i mean it's kurt chilling he
thought he could do everything you know
the
the the the bravado to think pull this
off yeah
but like if he had to shut down in march
and give everyone two months of
severance
it would have prevented a lot of lives
from being just totally upended and
and really really damaged um and a union
could have done that and that that's
that's one of the things that i explore
in the book is like the protections that
a union can offer
for for and unions are certainly not
perfect they have their flaws but
that is one area in which they could
really help and just having a contract
in place for workers could really be
successful
yeah i absolutely agree and i love how
you you balance the thought process
not the end-all be-all the safe
everything but it could have been a
protection in that in this case again
with several
nopes yeah absolutely lord daniel
continue sir yeah
um and this isn't the question i was
going to but just to like uh
put myself into this section's
conversation i
was remember reading that last chapter
and i almost had like a uh
i had to realign what i was thinking
about because i'm so used to reading
just
all these seemingly short stories about
video game development from either your
books
your reporting but then this last
chapter
you turn it into like this argument
of we have this problem in the industry
that we oh that i just spent the rest of
the book
outlining here are some legitimate um
options that we can uh at least explore
and so like the one thing that i came
away thinking
specifically today is that a blood sweat
and pixels might be
the book that a lot of people in the
game industry want to read
press reset is the book that people in
the games industry
need to read yeah facts i agree so
anyway um the question i did have uh
lined up
um we've talked a lot about how crunch
culture
affects people in triple a studios like
we were talking about with halo infinite
uh
at the beginning of the show uh the
thing that i wanted to ask you
what is the indie equivalent of the aaa
culture story of the
of the crunch well crunch culture
specific i mean crunch culture can
happen anywhere it's not something that
like every many people in america
especially have issues with work-life
balance
because it's considered like a badge of
honor to be able to work a lot and to
to to be considered like passionate and
in some ways that can be a good thing
um and in other ways it could be a
really horrible thing um
crunch culture is just an epidemic
especially like like
uh when you're working remote and
there's no commute and so you can really
just be working constantly yeah i mean
work-life balance is a real issue it's
like
in any field it's not unique to gaming
um and
similarly and it's not unique to aaa
gaming indie developers can crunch just
as art if not
if not harder um i think one of the big
differences
is that if you're an indie and if you
have
ownership over your project then you
stand to reap the benefits and i think
crunch is a very different thing when
you're
when you're like crunching at at uh i
don't know
60 000 a year and not getting paid over
time and maybe at the end of the project
you'll get like
a month off or something like that but
for the most part you're not getting
paid for your hours
versus hey i'm working on this indie
game where if it sells 100 000 copies
i'm going to make all that profit so i'm
crunching for that it's very different
world
but then the flip side of that can be
like if you have a family if you have
you have a partner
you can really just damage your
relationships by working all the time
and that's that's that's an epidemic
thing um yeah and in indie development
especially because so many people have
to like put on so many hats and like do
so many different jobs
um because if you're a team of 10 people
then maybe one person who's like a
programmer is also doing marketing and
also doing pr or like
one person who's an artist is also doing
finance because there's not enough
people to do everything
um so you can wind up just working your
ass off and and
it can be really tough but the benefits
can be worth it in the end
but again i mean this is something that
like like i think crunch culture is
really complicated and nuanced and i
don't think it's as simple as like
oh my god you're working overtime that's
bad um because it's
it's so much deeper than that and so
much more complicated than that
um as opposed to the volatility that i
talk about in press reset
where it's a little more kind of dry
like this is very this is an epidemic
issue and the fact that like
it's so hard for people to maintain a
job long term and a single company in
the games industry
is really a massive issue and like if
you ask people if you say hey
why did you leave the games industry
because there are a lot of people who
have left the games industry
oftentimes number one they're on their
list is layoffs i'm sick of the layoffs
i'm sick of
being being part of a shooting at studio
shutdown and crunch might be on the list
somewhere but in general i don't really
think that it's like
as as big an issue to a lot of people
right as like the layoffs and being
underpaid
and like sexism and misconduct and stuff
like that i
i probably got a chance to ask my
industry friends
why they move so much and i've never saw
that type of movement
in anything other than the military yeah
yeah
in the military you notice that oh i'm
going here
for six months and then i'll be
stationed here in six months but i mean
there's structure
in that in this area it seems like this
the same amount of movement but less
structure
and it's like concerning but i've never
really sat back to think about it and
i've always thought in the positive
realm
oh they might be going to a better
situation but then
reading the book you jump from one place
and then you go someplace else and it's
not
exactly what you thought and then you
have to move from that sinking ship to
the next sinking ship
and that is kind of frightening never
ending yeah and i think
so one of the things that i explore in
the book also is remote work which i
think could be a game changer for
the games and i'm very curious to see
what happens after kobe like if people
are
if companies are more inclined to like
let people work remotely because
that i think would change everything
like one of the reasons that that
people burn out is because when you're
in your 20s it's like okay i can move
around from places i'll go see a new
city for a couple years no big deal but
when you get older you've been working
for 10 years you're in your 30s you want
to have a family maybe you want to have
kids or
at the very least a partner you want to
live with someone or you have roots in a
city
you're just like man i don't want to
keep doing this anymore i can't be
moving around every time i get a new job
in the games industry every time i get
laid off so i'm just going to leave for
something that that is
is more stable and that i can actually
stay in here and that's what happened a
lot of people in boston rhode island and
like some of these cities where there
isn't a huge
games culture it's happening people in
new york
um it's funny the avalanche office and
the rockstar office were both around the
corner from the old gawker
office where i was at at kotaku so i
used to pass people
on the street in the morning and i would
be like is this a game developer or a
hipster
hipster like based on what they're
wearing but yeah no it was uh it's
it's it's i think remote work could
really change things and like
i'm imagining a lot of situations where
people who are older who have kids in
school that they don't want to take out
who maybe get laid off and maybe layoffs
can't be avoided but like if suddenly
they could get a job at any other games
company without having to move
suddenly you have access to all this
talent that like maybe wouldn't burn out
in the same way anymore and i think it
could just be a game changer for
for companies and people mm-hmm oh i
guess that would that would help the
studios themselves too
because yeah i'm sure that you know them
had
them have we've seen studios like
microsoft putting the initiative in
in aries because they know there's
talent there it's easier to hire people
if they're local
but if you can hire more people in terms
of remote access you
you you won't have to you could you
could put your studio anywhere at that
point but yeah i was just talking to
someone last night
who works for a prestigious aaa studio
and they were telling me like yeah well
we're not sure
like everybody's looking around and
trying to figure out what are we going
to do with remote work moving forward
because on one hand
a lot of people want it and there's
going to be a lot of talent out there
that
wants to work remotely on the other hand
it feels like morale has been down and
like it's hard to be creative when we're
all in different places and like
we feel like we miss out so much of our
culture we're not all in the office
together so there's definitely downsides
to the potential of remote work also it
can be an issue if you have like some
people in an office and then other
people remote
there can be like communication issues
and like you got to make sure everyone's
looped in
but like if you can make it happen um i
think it would really change like i
think the sacrifices are worth it the
trade-offs of those negatives
are worth it because like just being
accessible and not only not only is it
like a stability thing it's also like
there are people out there who like
maybe live in in
cities maybe they don't have a ton of
money maybe they live like in the middle
of the country in the middle of america
or like
places in europe or like in countries
that you don't think about a lot because
they don't
when it comes to games because they
don't have like big game development
scenes
and maybe those people are super
talented and like having access to them
without making them spend money to move
because they can't afford to move
suddenly you have access to all this
talent that like you wouldn't otherwise
and maybe the games industry could be
opened up to more people and you can get
more people of like
marginalized backgrounds and like poor
backgrounds and
it feels like it could really help a lot
of people in a lot of ways
what i could see is when you start at a
company
like you know i don't know if if you're
just a contractor or something
those people can probably be you know
remote because they're not
really necessarily part of the plug it
but you know
probably once like the company itself
has taken you more seriously then
they're like yeah you're probably gonna
have to move to the air you know well
certain positions we know
will definitely you know have to be
located from from a collaborative
standpoint mocap
you know things of that nature there's
certain positions that innately
you know will have to be that but um i i
do think you make a valid point because
the positive out of the pandemic is it
has forced a lot of companies to now
transition and work in this capacity and
maybe
they say to themselves with a lot with
certain positions certain roles that hey
we're saving overhead
you know and maybe that you know we're
still able to efficiently
get what we need done i just want to
move on some people have done mocap from
their homes by the way
no no no what was what was the with the
game that we saw
and um and we had to develop man
and they were doing they were hopping
over the the boxes that was inside the
house
uh oh the game is on the tip of my i
will get it
but it was it was well i mean i heard i
heard that
for uh miles morales they had people
working from
home yeah probably a lot of triple a
games that that have come out over the
past like year because
nobody's been able to especially
especially games that were coming out
at the end of last year so like like
were in product like if
they were being final in like the spring
of last year when nobody went anywhere
and everyone was like what the hell's
going on
everyone sanitizing their packages
at that point really nobody was trying
to go to mocap studios so i think a lot
of people just set up their own like
we're like all right well this is long
term we got to do stuff at home and
figure out how to make it work
but i do have one quick question for you
guys we got to respect his time
yeah obviously you are one of the people
in the industry i'd say a lot of
corporate
you know they they try to don't talk to
jace to try
don't jump to jason's truck has there
ever been a particular
you don't have to say who if there is i
just curious that there is
is every particular like publisher or
any kind of story that you try to get
but it's like almost impossible no one
will talk to you in that place
yeah all the time no all the time there
are stories that i've tried to pursue
and
tried to get and yeah i mean for every
story i published there are probably
five other stories that i've tried to
try to figure out how to get and either
couldn't for a variety of years i mean
there
are all sorts of reasons why story might
not happen um
might not be able to find enough people
might not find the right people might
hear conflicting things from people and
not be able to
figure out what was true there are
bazillion reasons um but
to your point i've heard i i won't say
the company but i heard
that um one company one big company
has like a whole training session that's
like like their standard training
sessions and
one of the beats in their presentation
or whatever it's the don't talk to press
one and they
specifically say like do not talk to
jason
how does it feel jason that they when
they're sit they're doing their little
team meetings like could they click a
button there's a big picture
it doesn't operate it's so flattered i'm
so flattered
that's amazing and i've heard anecdotes
about like people in meetings being like
don't leak this to jason dryer like come
on guys
wow which i think is funny yeah no it's
flattering i mean
yeah like at the end of the day it's
it's that to me
like i mean i'm doing my job and yeah
sorry i'm here for absolutely i want to
respect respect your town lord jason
because i know where we're going
if possible i wanted to be able to sneak
in the uh at least the first topic with
you how'd you do it on time yeah
okay cool so before i get a few more
minutes okay cool so
just like i said salute to you you know
definitely with the
you know one thing i love about the book
first of all everyone go pick up this
book if you want to learn about the
games industry
please you know pick up because these
are the reality these are the stories
you don't hear a lot about the human
stories
and um you know it's really cool to see
also what i love that you did is
you had that solution chapter yeah let's
see that's that's the biggest part
um i mean it's always great to you know
highlight whatever issues that's going
on or to
go into detail about issues and problems
and stuff like that
right and the human nature side of it
but then at the end of the day
you should have thoughts and solutions
and i like the fact that he does have
thoughts
to make it better for anybody that
thinks jason is just the person that
you know throws the rock and hides his
hands
that's what they say and the reality is
i just want to hurry up because we gotta
you gotta keep on the time but um
the reality is there's so many great
points made
you know a few of them we talked about
unionization as an option not saying
it's a save or end or be all but
that's an option there's some
protections there we talked about re
remote work and things of that nature
you know what i'm saying
so like and even outsourcing studios or
certain things you know i'm saying that
that's a cool thing so i just believe
studios
yes shout out to disbelief i want to
salute you there um quickly because i do
want to sneak in the first topic with
you at least if we can yeah
with the xbox one um yeah so basically
you know
20 years man 20 years of xbox
this will be the celebration and um
looks like microsoft's going to be going
pretty hard
as far as um marketing and xbox 20 and
things of that nature but
i wanted to ask you this lord jason like
in reference to this like oh why is
x why is this king doing the wakanda x
forever but anyway oh no no
no i wasn't doing that oh god
i thought you were letting it breathe
upon you or something
forever just stop okay i apologize that
was me being present
so like yeah lord jason like what does
that mean to you for number one you know
at 20 years of xbox
and then number two to addict's question
because he wanted to throw this in
you know side like kind of funny because
we got we brought up halo way for a lot
this podcast
like you know does halo infinite
need to be a game of the year candidate
for you so a two part
yeah um 20 years of xbox it's it's
pretty cool
it's like it was it seemed impossible
back when it launched that like
microsoft could come out and compete
with like
the industry uh titans oh i guess
playstation hadn't been around that long
but it still felt because they had final
fantasy and metal gear and like
it felt like they were really dominant
and obviously nintendo had been around
forever
and yeah it's it's cool that microsoft
has stuck with it and and
done all this cool stuff in games and
like it feels like microsoft now
is in a stronger position than they've
ever been in because of game pass
and um i think a lot of people are just
waiting for the other shoe to drop on
game fest what's gonna happen here
because
it just seems too good to be true with
the amount of stuff you get for that
price
like when are they going to raise the
price like what's the what's the catch
here what's the kind of you get the
catch right
um but yeah they're in a good position
i'm not a huge fan of like the
consolidation and buying every studio
and
just it feels very like monopoly like
which i'm not a huge fan of
but but um yeah xbox isn't a good place
it's which is great because like
competition is really good and it's
where everything is healthier when uh
all three
of the big console makers are doing well
um i think it makes things way better
it makes companies have to compete and
have to like um
um keep up with one another like you i i
think my
sony for example is gonna be forced to
compete with microsoft when it comes to
xbox game pass et cetera et cetera so
yeah i mean i think it's it's really
cool it's good to see it's good to see
that xbox has been thriving and
um i think phil spencer has done a
really good job shepherding this thing
and and by many accounts seems like a
good boss and a good guy to
to be running this company yeah i think
xbox is in a really good place
you know that said yeah i mean i think
that they're still
kind of struggling with their software
development for a variety of reasons
um i think there's a lot of just
vestigial like remnants of problems
they've had in the past
i think microsoft is just a very
difficult company for
when it comes to game development
because the company's culture is very
much like a
software development company and that's
what at their heart that's what they are
still
it's like a software service company
like microsoft office and all that stuff
so it's it's difficult for games to to
like really be able to thrive in a way
that they should
and i think 343 has definitely uh
definitely been
been the victim of some of that culture
and they've had their own problems and
um i think a lot of microsoft owned
companies
have had issues as for halo infinite
being the the game of the year
um our game of the year candidate should
it be i don't think
should it be i mean will it be i i i
don't know who knows
the thing is i've said this before but
like when it comes to
aaa game development every single game
seems to have the same problems it's
like
our tools suck like our leadership is
couldn't stick with the direction
like we all crunched all these issues
like
all these standard issues in game
development and then the line between
all of those problems leading to um a
failure and a masterplace is just like
raising a masterpiece razor thing um
for every like uh cyberpunk there's a
god of war
which had many of those same issues but
somehow they managed to pull it off and
they made this incredible game so with
hillary like i don't even think
even right now if you ask people on the
game i don't think they would know the
answer to like is this going to be a
great game because i think it's
very hard to tell until you're at the
end of things and it's like okay this is
shaping up
okay this is not shaping up um i think
it's going to do really well
i think it's gonna be cool um hopefully
it's great i
i certainly hope so i want it to be
awesome um i'm happy it's coming to pc
as for game of the year canada i don't
know i mean that that question
i don't think the concept of i think the
concept of game this is a whole nother
conversation
game of the year is asinine because like
games are so many like like there
there's so many different types of games
and almost looping
them all together as video game feels
like it doesn't make
sense anymore um like
just because there's so many different
genres and so many types of games and so
much scale
of games that it just doesn't make sense
like how do you compare
threes as like the the perfect mobile
game uh
halo infinite it's just a different it's
like almost like the concept of game of
the year is kind of silly that's why i
really don't subscribe to it
yeah but as far as i think in general
when we talk about game of the year
we're talking about like
what's going to be the best triple-a
game of the year
it doesn't really resonate with me at
all but all right so always
the question i just really want to ask
him because i know his time is very
limited yeah yeah and you touched on
something that i've always
viewed and you touched on that that
microsoft is a software company
right and being at the fact that their
software company the way they
they move and they have uh they hire
instruction stuff like that like he was
talking about
uh on pading work and uh on all the
contracts and they're going in and out
and it's and if you're plugging people
in and you're plugging people out that
really doesn't work so well in the game
industry and making games where
sony uh is um they come from a movie
background they come from different type
of structure
and they actually like watch the
mirrored nintendo stuff
early on and that you know actually grew
their
their stuff i remember them in the
beginning my question to this is
is microsoft acquisition of bethesda
more important to microsoft's
gaming as far as the culture that was at
bethesda because we always
every time we went to e3 it seems like
bethesda
always knew and always had that culture
that microsoft needed as far as the
flair that these yeah everything
their products yeah i always thought
this stuff was really
you know well done as far as games and
promotion and how to do just flair stuff
just to just
the culture do you think that culture
would transfer
over to to microsoft in this acquisition
and i know we talked about
remote stuff but just for the people
that's on site that get a chance to
live and breathe inside that environment
that's a good question i think microsoft
traditionally has
when they publish companies they let
them be kind of autonomous and they've
said they're going to do that with
bethesda but like you look at like
uh skype and like linkedin and all these
other big companies that microsoft has
published
they're generally just kind of left to
do their own thing and so there isn't a
lot of like
culture like um merging and like people
getting to know each other and stuff
like that it kind of feels more like
it's a bunch of different entities that
just all happen to be online microsoft
just so far that's what we've seen with
gaming sorry go ahead no i'm gonna say
just to
push back a little um yeah we've had a
lot of
um microsoft studios on we've had
obsidian on we've had
compulsion on and undead labs right and
one of the things that i thought was
promising because i've always been a fan
of sony
i feel their strength in the sense of
collaboration from studios right
and i think in the past maybe say during
the 360 era we didn't see that a lot
right but one of the stories that we're
continuing to hear when we spoke to
obsidian
in the narrative team and we spoke to
these like this this cross collaboration
where they may say hey you know
hey rare you guys do water well right
let's get you in there hey obsidian you
guys did this great thing with native
let's get you in
and i'm hearing these even compulsion
like we've had in the morning and
they're saying hey you know we spoke to
this team and then
all the studio heads together in these
collaborative
moments kind of working again and that
to me gave me a little hope that
they're working as unified team to kind
of make themselves better
so like do you feel this kind of culture
change can like
truly trickle down and affect the
culture of like whether
the way the games are presented the way
the games end up being produced
underneath
the microsoft banner so to speak or do
you think some of that is overstated
yeah well i think there's a difference
between like hey we're gonna powwow like
every couple of months and like have our
big summit where all the studio heads
get together and like
talk about whatever all the writers get
together and and talk about writing and
how to how to learn from each other and
i think that's really cool and can be
super beneficial but that's a little bit
different than like merging cultures and
essentially the only way to really like
merge cultures is to have your is to
just combine
your teams put them all together in one
office see what happens and that can be
both a good and a bad thing depending on
the culture sometimes they mix together
like oil and water and it's just like a
disaster
um i do think that that bethesda i mean
yeah certainly like i'm sure they will
be learning from each other in a lot of
ways that are
that are useful um but i wouldn't be
shocked if for example like bethesda had
their own e3 press conference even
separately from microsoft
like i wouldn't be shocked if that was
the case i would also put a flashlight
i also wouldn't be shocked if microsoft
just had it all under their umbrella
like i could see them going either way i
don't know
um i think it's still very early in this
kind of relationship and i'm very
curious to see
what happens yeah i mean
and also part of it is that like we're
we're still in the middle of covid and
yes people can't really
get together in person as much um
anymore
so so that that kind of changes the idea
of like what a culture is anyway because
like
culture over zoom calls is very
different than culture over uh very true
and when you're in the office together
so yeah i don't know i'm very curious to
see what happens
very true so look we gotta respect the
time any final question for anyone lord
anyone because we've got to get him out
of here on time the man has to enjoy his
days sundays
work hard we got to go back to mass
effect exactly right he did everything
and he followed questions
for jason from the panel from the round
table
i mean jason what what do you hope to
accomplish with this book
um well i mean i just hope that that it
informs people and people like reading
it and and
come away from it feeling like they've
learned stuff and
been entertained and informed and
interested and and hopefully
um give some more thought to like
playing games and the cost it takes
sometimes to make them
um i think it's kind of like like a
secondary
uh hope after that is that like some
people
in decision making positions uh uh read
it
um some executives some people who are
actually studio ads and say hey wait a
minute like we need to
we need to make sure that this doesn't
happen to us and we need to do something
about it
but but first and foremost i just want
to make sure readers out there like
your average person who is like whether
they're a fan of games or not just like
finds the book interesting and yes and
enjoys reading it and and
comes away from it feeling like they've
learned stuff that's that's my main
absolutely we love what you're doing you
know again must read material if you're
a gamer it's absolutely must read
material
again thank you legendary lord
jason schreyer of bloomberg news
rocking out back in the room man man
it's always a pleasure to have you and i
love that we have real discussions real
talk
nothing's off the table with you and i
love that aspect about you your
transparency
and uh real quick story yeah shout out
to everybody watching who i blocked on
twitter
if you're watching and you've been
blocked on twitter and you feel like
maybe you shouldn't be blocked on
twitter
send me an email and send me your
twitter handle and i'll look you're
gonna do that advanced
do me a
if you said something crappy to me and
you feel bad about it then
just apologize and i'll unlock you
that's easy
if you feel like i i blocked you
unjustly
then let me know and i will uh look you
up and call you out if
need be um but yeah i mean and then we
can work things out
at the end of the day i maybe i don't
make this clear enough to people maybe i
should but like i
very much believe in second chances and
i do believe that people deserve the
chance
to change i don't believe that everybody
deserves a chance to
like get to interact with me on twitter
and like get to get my ear
i don't believe that everybody deserves
my attention but like if you feel like
uh
i i did you wrong by blocking you then
let me know
he said hi
shout out to all the people who say hey
you blocked me for
disagree and then i in 10 seconds i look
you up and like you
you you you like the most horrible thing
you're just like jason you dirty jew
that's not disagreement every single
time every single time
like just happened an hour ago every
single time
now i respect you for that and again
like i said you know that is that is a
cool
way of handling it and one thing i never
told you this i got to tell you for you
without is um
you know because i used to have like i
said these discussion people like oh
well maybe he's dick picking or whatever
whatever and
i never told you this but the year that
we met i believe that was you still
kataku was may solve addict
and um you know we we met you with that
indeed
it was it's like the e3 we meet you
right right yeah and then e3 god i
missed you i missed it
i missed you so much brother it was so
cool but one thing i never told you this
is um
in e3 remember how you have the
different halls you had the one that had
the cafeteria the big stuff
but it was that one and i was just
sitting there minding my business
i was eating my little sandwich and you
didn't realize
like you were two like tables away from
me and i'm not gonna put out the person
who you were
interviewing but you were getting you
were working i seen the investigative
journalism in action you were very
respectful
they were they were talking to you and
the way you handled it
and i was like wow he he wasn't looking
for like i told people
literally all the misconceptions you
have about he's just looking for these
stories
and you know it was really cool and the
professionalism you exuded so i wanted
to salute to you soon to the cafeteria
you know listen i was able to ease y'all
i'm sorry i said a little bit yeah
i have no idea like i've had so many
conversations at e3 that yeah
keep making these books every time you
have a discussion with any one of e3
some security to come up like
yeah john we're going to say the
developer's name
john we're going to have to ask you to
to leave the premises please
oh my god lord daniel you want to say
your outros to uh lord jason man
me uh yeah i i
want to thank you again so much for uh
sending me the uh press copy
uh i think it was literally like 10
minutes after you tweeted
saying hey if you're writing for a
smaller publication let me know i'll be
willing to hook you up
uh this is one of the uh best
experiences i've had
writing for lords of the game for the
past two and a half years at this point
wow i am really excited to see what else
you do in the future hopefully we can
meet in person at some point thank you
thank you thank you i appreciate it yeah
hopefully on the streets of e3
yes yes no doubt lord addict your final
outros to lord
jason the legend yeah definitely want to
apologize for me missing
30 40 minutes of the show again it's all
good notice that he's going to play the
game after he does the podcast
just a little guard just a little dark
i'ma ignore you
you know i got to give you a shout out
right little jay said like
you know obviously you got your haters
that i love shutting them down on
twitter because it's so easy
because they're like oh this person does
this this person i was like
then show me link be another person that
does what jason does link be one person
and guess what jason they quite crickets
every time
it's like it's like look at the other
day you you could disagree with how you
had to your twitter you could disagree
with how
your your opinions but you can't
disagree with the work
that's what he does is and he does it
very well professionalism no
doubt lord solve i chose the lord jason
jason i
i mean you you exude new york attitudes
that's my favorite yeah
you don't take you don't take any smack
and sometimes the moments when i've
disagreed with
with how you've handled stuff and then
like you said it comes right back to
you know they'll be private
conversations just sort of immediate
rate situations and things like that so
i i just love that about you and i
i wish you you said that outwardly more
that hey
i'm not you know i'm not i'm just not
shutting people down
um and with that said i i would like to
at some point
have a more in-depth conversation with
you about the state of the industry i
would love to to have that comment let's
do it
hit me up anytime there you go solve
excuse exclusive let's go
in a few months when i'm uh when you're
arrested
i'm so exhausted from this lord king
outros you got your people to stand down
i respect that
yeah leave him alone um though those
actually was lower ranking foul
i must say as a fellow jets fan
i know your skin is tough
yeah trust me that we deal with it all
the time um and we got hope this season
um do we though i was just i i yeah
don't worry we'll talk about this
i was just telling you that like like no
matter how much optimism you have for
the jets it's like
you're still the jazz
zach wilson man we'll see i don't know i
already saw i saw this stuff
just like last week i saw this stuff
about his mom
oh yeah we have to shut her down oh my
god is the jets a football team
oh god wow anyway
but also as a fellow new yorker you know
um you put the right person
in charge what is this and that can fix
so we saw with the knicks
we saw with uh microsoft with you know
phil dominance maximus really is
in position we can actually change the
culture in certain things and hopefully
we have a brighter future but
to you sir um a real journalist
facts like you know and this that's
that's why i just had to make it really
clear to people
that it's you just don't put journalists
under somebody's name you earn that and
you know
you strive very hard for that and that
is that shows in your
body of work and what i what i like from
this latest book is the fact that you
gave solutions
at the end of the situation and people
need to take that so instead of putting
him
don't talk to jason how about you read
his book and how about you go and say oh
maybe you should talk to jason because
if he's the topic of your intro i think
maybe you don't want to work there
because
that means then there's some underlining
problems with the company
that you're worried about
have you ever have you ever had a lot of
like has there ever been a lot of like
feedback coming from those studios that
they want to clear something up
or for the most part once once you
reveal real distinct they just they they
just stay away
i just want to say one last thing is
thank you for being the boogie man in a
lot of these dudes closets
and some people be shocked yeah baby
yeah
yeah no to to addict to your question
yeah usually it's just
silence which is which i think is sad i
think these companies should talk and
would like
it would be beneficial for them to like
put their executives and give them
interviews and like let me tell a fairer
story because a story is never gonna be
as fair as it could be unless it gets
every voice in the equation yeah these
companies never want to do it these
companies like believe that
if they shut up then maybe the problems
will go away and it's
i think it's sad i think it's a bummer
i'd love to get on the phone with all
these
all these execs and all these managers
and all these ceos but uh but yeah
mostly it's silence occasionally someone
will talk to me off the record and be
like hey actually
like try to get me not to talk about
something or whatever but mostly it's
silence
well look glorious absolute pleasure
enjoy your sunday brother looking
forward to thank you back in the room
everybody pick up press reset have a
good brother always cool pleasure thank
you man thank you yeah thanks for all
the
all the kind words everybody and yeah
see you guys see you guys next time lord
jason schreier no doubt
and of course lord daniel may from lords
of gaming.net pulling
up with tremendous article on that book
you know what i'm saying tell them
what's going on with you what other
cool articles and opinion pieces you got
going on at lawrence.net sir
well so obviously i had the review for
press reset up that went up last tuesday
i also
wrote an op-ed about how i've seen the
things that jason highlighted
in press reset in my it's gonna be
four years out of college this week um
and then i promise even though this is
almost like two or three weeks after
release we are getting a new pokemon
snap review i'm
almost done with that game
by the end of the month that i promise
bro i want to shout you out because i'm
glad you can make this
you know we always try to reward our
writers with stuff like that eugene
hector i mean the whole team you guys
killed but you've been one of the og's
and
i got i got to give a shout out you know
to recipes to the homie uh lord dizzy
because
you were his champion you were his he
was like i'm telling you this kid man
just to see your growth i know you work
in life sometimes
gets in the way but when you contribute
you're you're clearly one of the best
and
it's a pleasure to have you extreme
professionalism sky's the limit for you
always glad to help you and support you
and yo check out his articles y'all
lords of gaming.net man this guy was
dizzy's number one draft pick
and now mine mama
lord daniel may brother salute to your
brother daniel
they're calling you theon greyjoy
that's the funniest joy ever whoever
said
here for real
no man a pleasure brother enjoy your
sunday bro
we'll deal with these super chats thank
you let's get to super chats
okay okay let me roll back a little bit
here
we go
we got cedric h with the 10 super chat
keep up the great work lords
thank you sir then we got reggie mobile
nine with the five dollars of attack
loot to the lords i wish more
journalists would like jason schreier
ruffle some feathers and tell some
truths
less lies and hidden mess salutes
facts then we got urban ninja with the
five dollars
yeah we like them already that's exactly
why i didn't jump in myself
got a comp science uh a computer science
degree just couldn't put myself through
that
yeah it's uh game dev is is is tough
then we got mr bad bit with the five
dollar stupid snack
greetings lords random question for
jason it's been two thousand two hundred
forty four days since the release of
bloodborne
when's that sequel happening please give
me hope i forgot to ask that but
i i don't think it's ever happening
they'll remix it again then we have a k
mega ten dollars with the chat that's
good support thank you brother
then we have j dub as a shell with the
five dollar super chat
does anyone know when returner will hit
the 20 digital bargain thing
asking for a friend who thinks 70
dollars is a rip-off for rebugnol
i mean return in two weeks uh then we
have
flame with the five dollar super chat to
jason's point there's passionate crunch
then they're slave driving
youtuber noodle made an excellent video
on this with marty o'donnell
noodle yeah people always always try to
say oh
i worked overtime last week i crunched
it's dead it's not the same
not the same then we have so petty so
petty with the 10
super chat just in case any devs are
listening can we get a quantum realm
ant-man game
okay um then we have shawn
with the two super chat is there an
audio version of jason's book uh we
didn't ask him that but there was an
audio version
i spoke to him offline yeah um it was
delayed so it should be next week so
next week will be the audio from
whatever
is he narrating it or is it something no
no no no dude who plays noctis
yes i always knock this from you phantom
fantasy cool
professional oh he's on it then we have
dan lazzaro five dollar super chat
addy gonna show up late and not brush
his hair or anything
that nickname is spitting today jesus
jesus christ
why are y'all worried about my being
here
kind of weird man
they think they care too much about this
i take that criticism a little bit more
if it was a woman but you
do
listen as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got then we have brett bingham with
the twenty dollars of a chat
i'm a very skeptical person by nature
however i'm cautiously optimistic that a
storm is brewing at xbox
and phil spencer bain of jim ryan
bane of sony
phil will be smiting fools wow very
dominance talk
there's hope um the man who got them
horns
we got playing through emmy1 remastered
remind me of one thing i always knew
ashley's the space racist quote
i can't tell the aliens from the animals
yeah ashley hashtag i'm not reading that
thank you
yeah you read that song yeah i'm not
reading that
but thank you that's effect to love
salute okay the truth hurts the truth
listen i came to a realization with cog
over the um at the barbecue
that he's wrong he's wrong no we have to
we have to accept this right
yeah if if the first one doesn't lay the
ground work oh yeah
yeah someone doesn't show up it's
supposed to
it's supposed to be better than the
first to do
things that are interesting better
listen i understand where you stand with
it because i stand with you
i stand with you i know yourself no just
joke
he said i just revealed myself no
you know what's funny the beef that i
have understand
though the beef that i have with the
mass effect 2 crew is their thing was
okay don't improve on it just eliminate
it
kill it but i love y'all i love y'all
malik tyler5
you know what's going to happen it's
just waiting on e3 so i can see what
microsoft got
also battlefield 6. yes everybody's been
and and stop and stop calling for andy
mcnamara's head please people this is
ridiculous
they they champion that game but don't
go buy the game when it comes out listen
stop stop stop it stop
it but what it is they have because it's
modern this time no more
four scores seven years
suicide kings two dollars super chat
note to addict you pay her to leave
oh
look i was gonna say some crazy stuff
[Laughter]
someone could take a shot at me but i
can't take it no i get it i
get it i get it that was a
that was uh who's the dude that punches
in the nuts all the time
that's all jokes
um lord addict man 20 years xbox what it
mean to you
and um also your halo situation game the
incident
uh 20 years man i i remember
it's it's been a long 20 years that's
you you're young
[Laughter]
i mean it's not my fault like you'd be
an actor
you know what i mean you know i got it
i remember you know back in the day
playing
playing halo i didn't really get into
gears
but you know it's always been one of
those things that xbox has definitely
been one of like the pillars of my life
you know obviously playstation nintendo
has too but
you know people can say what they want
about the xbox brand
without the xbox brand i don't think the
gaming industry would be the same
you know i i think that we would have
got
to where we are with the internet yeah
but i think microsoft
excelled it by like five years right so
you know
it's hard to tell like microsoft
inventing the online scene the way they
did for consoles
it it it could have without that we
don't we might not even be where we are
in terms of internet infrastructure
obviously
when something evolves in one area the
the cable companies got to take it to
the next area to
to incorporate yo the people people
making a lot
there's a lot of money to be made in
this internet stuff man we
we gotta improve it so like you know
people
one thing i have to say too is i think
that we have microsoft to think for
where the first person shooter market is
because i i think that halo elevated it
on console
but call of duty is what put it to the
next level but i i agree with you
because
dr cut you made a i'm not gonna let you
go run past that
p prior to halo the the consensus was
you really can't do
it can't be done console i mean without
mouse and keyboard a mouse keyboard on
joint and don't get we had golden all
stuff before
but nothing was on halo's level at that
time that changed the game and proved
that not only could it be done
it was revolutionary because even king
we've had this discussion before
ai lighting it was also a graphical show
piece
in conjunction with the story yeah the
story i mean it merged everything at a
point where
we didn't see that and it was it was uh
it was a unicorn standing in the field
so
they when it made people take notice you
know
when it gets to me i'll talk to how i
feel about it
you know i honestly think that we're
seeing you know evolution and racing
games because of forza
you know clearly sooner or later
someone's got to catch up with them in
quality
and if if you don't have that quality
then
what's crazy is microsoft is dominating
a genre that isn't locked out
like like a madden or or like a 2k like
like people can compete with them but
the game is so
dominant that no one wants to try really
but do you
you know addict that was competition
because
for a long time sony had a lock on it
with gran turismo
and the forza team took that challenge
and i didn't really think there was ever
gonna be uh
gran turismo to be honest with you
because i remember not even a car racing
dude but
getting gran turismo sovereign knows
that we will get the japanese game
and play it before it even came out
because that was the pinnacle of raisin
and to your point at it for them to meet
the challenge
and to exceed them in every damn
category
speaks volumes to that studio and
microsoft as a whole
i think you're onto something sir i'm
sorry i gotta change the subject
shout out to daniel he literally changed
his avatar twitter to theory
y'all peep your man
he literally changes twitter to this i'm
like yo he's messy salute to him
you know the next thing about halo like
look like
i get it i love halo i've always loved
it
hey halo is one of the i think i've
always gravitated more towards fable
than halo when it comes like the
original xbox titles
but like let's be real here you guys
there's nothing they could do to ever
get halo to where it was and the only
reason that is
is because back when halo was popping
there was a
fortnight there was no war zone like it
it's not necessarily that halo's fallen
from grace which it has a little bit
it is that the competition around
halo has grown to or above halo right
it is like look like at the end of the
day
halo's still a beloved franchise but how
do you compete with fortnite
how do you compete i mean they had to
make the multiplayer
a a free to play just to even remotely
compete with it
and what but what if that hits though
adding what if that really does hit
people are excited to play something
that's free and what is it on everything
they had to make it free they had to
make it free right but what
i i think you answered your own question
there right how do they bring back that
greatness i think that the thing is
is when it comes to when it comes to the
overall skill
fortnite takes skill to play at the
higher level
but it's not as skillful to play at the
casual level when you're just walking in
you get in there do your couple games
leave then you can just unplug
right halo's not like that halo has a
very
a weird skill gap that a lot of casual
people can't get into
and one of the things that i see people
always talking about they love comparing
it to casual games
and it's not a casual game i don't know
anyone in here thinking
halo's a casual game go play halo 5
right now you know i get what you're
saying and
you drop in there but you have sweaties
so what about a comparison to war zone
right all right forget about because
fortnite is on another level right
fortnite is is that game that
appeals to everybody right it'll appeal
to a eight-year-old kid as well as a
35-year-old man
what about comparing it to war zone and
how it could function in that space
you know the difference between halo and
warzone is right now
warzone is still capitalizing golf with
fortnite because it's a battle royale
game
right yeah i think halo needs to go that
route oh they doing that
i think for sure i think that's
happening know whether it comes out at
launch is another story
it's like you know it's something has to
to give in that space
with that game and at the end of the day
i got to call you out brad
gotcha like going after the chocolate
at the end of the day i would prefer
them
to aim more towards what i want as a
halo fan
what people want as halo no let's be
real here
no they they got to go towards the halo
fans they got to like
i get it like in order to open it up to
the to the masses
the casual open up is making it free to
play okay
that's okay but at the end of the day
when it comes to that game in general
i want them to try to appeal to a halo
fan then try to casualize the game up
and then lose the halo fan yeah and the
only real way that you get to that point
is have high quality or is it or it
changes the industry right
look i don't think halo's going to be
like a low quality game or anything like
that
but when it comes to to halo they got
more to worry about than god of war
god of war only worries about one aspect
a single player
driven experience right like halo
is one of the few open first person
shooters or
shooters in general that they can't just
get away with one or the other right
they got to do both of them
let me let me ask you this slow-mo is
actually saying something i was thinking
about
like what what do you say to like okay
we could admit that halo on some level
lost a little bit of appeal
as opposed to its hay so what about the
mindset addict of like
well don't you want that base that that
casual base that
you know the fortnight the the war zone
guys to come in and
and not that you got to completely
casualize halo but with that mode or
just bring you got to bring those people
in to take it to the next level
the thing is to bring those people in
you have to casualize the game
and i don't want to casualize in the
game i i've seen
beloved franchises of mine make moves
to get a bigger audience and it made for
a worse product in general
final fantasy people didn't like the art
the the the turn bases
they got so much criticism so 12 they
decide they're going to go away from the
turn base
10 is the last game i love definitely
every year it gets more and more casual
and i'm sure there's people in this comp
this chat right now
that has a franchise that they love
right that they try to chase the bag
instead of chasing the fans okay fair
enough so so but are you against like
modern updates remember when there was
80s and sprint
some people were hardcore mad against
are you against that too like no
i'm not against that because to me that
doesn't make halo
like i've never talked to a halo fan i'm
like you know what what
what do you like about halo they've
never said you know what addict i like
you can't run
you know what else i like attic i like
that you can't you can't aim down sights
i i've never felt like that table halo
was about math control
okay halo was about okay leveraging the
map to win the game
don't change the the the core game play
so to speak as opposed to modernizations
or certain things
okay okay i'm moving on let me get a lot
of man um let's get back focus
20 years of xbox first and uh just in
the halo of it i mean 20 years is crazy
man
um xbox is special for for
for us as a group you guys can age
is really special for us as a group
because if you remember
when they announced xbox a lot of the uh
sort of the reaction in the industry was
nah we don't believe that they're in it
we don't believe
right we don't believe that they're
serious right we don't believe they're
serious and i remember me being you know
i was i was super optimistic just
because i'm like
look man my sega's gone
and it's not like yeah and and this is
this company that's coming in to sort of
yeah to sort of take over those range
right i mean
the black box it just felt like even if
we didn't even know about those sort of
connections between sega and xbox at the
time it felt like that was the
replacement
and and and so i was all in and i wasn't
worried about you know people saying
these are the windows guys this isn't
gonna work or whatever i was super
excited
and i just i remember specific moments
like i remember
king me uh lord rick um lord uh
jose we went the day that that council
went up for pre-order we go
to the manhattan mall we go to eb games
and everybody gets their pre-orders
right and i just remember us going to
breakfast
after that being so excited for for halo
project gotham and alive 3.
and just it it was just a special time
and then the day we went to pick up our
consoles i remember we were pissed off
because
we didn't realize that eb games was
beholden to
when the mall when the mall with them
all so
everybody who got their stuff from a
store that was out in the street
had six a.m seven a.m eight a.m openings
for the console
we had to wait until 10 30 maybe 11
o'clock for the
wall to open for us to get our consoles
so we were pissed off because you were
right outside
at the game stop across the street or
whatever that was electronic boutique
on the corner yeah yeah it was something
else and and we were just like man we
should have done that but whatever so we
had to wait
um but i just remember that first day
man i threw on the first thing i
went from least excitement to most
excitement right
i threw on project gotham yeah and i'm
like this kid we always do that we
thought
and i throw down this rabbit hole of
ripping all of my tracks to the to the
to the console
and i'm playing project god i'm getting
i was like oh this is amazing as a fan
of metropolis street racer on the
dreamcast i'm like this is it this is
amazing so then after that we went to
dead or alive but you know our history
was dead or alive
yes all the way back to the original
saturn dead alive was 60 fps
beautiful the unshaven final yo and to
see what that game looked like on that
xbox
oh yes it was jaw-dropping it was
so amazing to see that game on that xbox
and i played that for a couple of hours
and i said all right
let me have some dinner and then it's
time to put the show on
oh yeah and i throw on halo
and we get the music that's the music
immediately just right there
the music hits you the fact that when
you're escaping the pillar of autumn
um and you and you realize that you have
a flashlight on your gun
that illuminates dark areas
it's crazy and then when you finally
land on halo and you see the
scope of the game oh and it's like whoa
what is this here i am i hung up i
called king i called [ __ ]
and i'm like have you played halo yeah
like now we haven't played it yet stop
doing it
um and for me and and that was it i was
in on xbox
since that moment yeah and they've been
ups and they've been downs that
you know the greatness with the 360 the
missteps with the xbox one
but i do like attic said they've they've
done things and pushed the industry
forward in ways that i think we'd be way
behind on if they hadn't
they're doing it right now with game
pass yeah they're doing it right now
again
they continue to take they continue to
get to take punches to the face
um for the industry to sort of accept
new norms
and and i don't think that's changing
anytime soon
i'm excited at the fact now that the
changes that they're making
people are gamers are excited for as
well right
and these investments that they made in
bethesda and all that stuff to me
it's just a i'm very excited for the
future of
xbox as a brand um i just really think
they finally
figured it out and they're using their
their muscle their
wallet to make it happen um
i know jason mentioned he doesn't like
the consolidation and i
understand i understand those concerns
right but when you have
competition coming from the amazons and
the googles and stuff like that
who's whose core sort of gameplay
philosophy and tencent right
their philosophy is different than what
we know as as core gamers and console
gamers and pc gamers
i i don't mind the big three making
investments to sort of shore up
their position in the end what i wanted
to jump on because i i know we had time
limited time because i wanted to push
back on
right further with that because you know
we talk about volatility
but at the same time what these
acquisitions
are doing is actually giving stability
and i wanted to really but i was like
damn we ain't got enough attention
that's going to develop into another
argument
i mean not arguing with a discussion and
you know should have salute to jason
yeah yeah i agree with you on microsoft
the stability and the fact that they are
trying to be hands off and let these
creators be creative as opposed to
with that but with that cushion of
knowing hey your job is secure like make
the game you want to make
right um i i think we need more of that
in the industry so i'm excited for that
you know what's funny solved me and uh
kyle was talking about that last night
is like
for some reason this is narrative that
people go and they're like
they're not buying bad studios like
these studios
with a limited budget a limited limited
budget
right in a fraction of some of these
have grown a double almost
like they they've made fantastic games
like
like i think obsidian is their best buy
to be honest with you out of all of them
because you you see obsidian
and when it looks at their past obsidian
i was talking to
last night what is obsidian not made in
the rpg
world i forgot they made quarter 2 they
made
they may fall in new vegas
thoughts park stick of truth
i mean and then you look over there too
yeah what yeah
i said stick of destiny yeah yeah oh oh
yeah actually yeah um south park yeah um
it yeah i think obsidian obsidian with
money
he's kind of it's kind of crazy i mean
it's very scary
money and i and i think it comes it
comes back to like
these studios have made some great games
with small budgets
and now they're able to take those ideas
and and blow them out a little bit more
and even if they
don't and even if they don't they just
they have the structure and they have
the stability to make even if they want
to make a small game
they don't have to worry about where
that next paycheck is coming from
and that's so big um so to the halo
question
man i really want halo to be
big and and i think the free to play
thing helps it sort of reach that larger
audience yeah
um but i think at the core like attic
said the single player has to be there
the story has to be there to appeal to
the core halo thing
that's the biggest thing i had is no
other shooters being held with those
standards anymore
no you don't see people you know what
god's story isn't right
you don't see people oh battlefield
stories lit
oh yeah i feel that's a good point where
heavy is there
like halo
is going to get spear bomb from two
different directions
well okay um we never wanted you xbox
there we go you weren't my choice
don't let them clip this i don't i don't
care
they can clip it they can write it down
they can post it on the wall they can do
whatever the hell they want to do so how
i said my sega
right yeah i wanted i wanted my sega i
feel it
but sega was uh a tale of two companies
trying to exist as one and it was not
the bee
um so microsoft and and they lineage
with sega
if people don't know i i suggest you go
research that
uh they are the spiritual successor i
tell you whenever there's a void in the
video
it's an xbox just king's rebound yes
yeah
she is beautiful in in
every way she stepped up to the plate
and she tried to make me forget about my
forgotten love
um you know she passed untimely
you know oh
it was an untimely death she went very
suddenly and into the height
and along comes xbox and
i'm trying to make me forget all the
segal
and i'm telling you any xbox fan
knows that and i know y'all probably
started on sega
and throughout the years and you hear
all these xyz buy sega
there's a reason why we want you right
now you're right you're right you
understand because we want that
old thing back we want our old one two
back we like those
moves that we used to do you understand
so
we we got ceos throughout the years and
i can tell you like we need an aaa
meeting
but i could tell you about my the first
time we went to all these shows
and microsoft has always been great at
this they've always been great at public
relations being with the public
out with the public showing their
products
and i can we we have countless shows and
stuff if we think back we were there
we were doing these things with it and
they endeared us to them
we had different ceos at different times
that did great things
you know i want to definitely give a
shout out to steve obama because without
him
it would ended the role would have ended
and he went forth and he put
back that ring of death could kill any
console developer
on this planet and he made sure that he
blocked that and that did not happen
um there's people along the way that
kept things going and it was people that
tried to tank us like the don
but along come phil fill along comes a
little shining light
that's from the company with and it's so
indicative of
microsoft's uh uh appeal of how the
company is
he grew from inside the company to
become the highest part
so far in his in the in that area
that he's in to become phil dominance
maximus are really expensive
and as addicts stated throughout the
years microsoft has
innovated in different areas of gaming
that push stuff forward that we have now
and shout out to jason ronald with quick
results
quick resume is amazing and you know um
it's little things that we don't know
that we need that they know that that we
need and they're implementing it
in ways that makes the quality of life
or that's why when i had to tell jason
uh my playstation was a waste for me for
now
right and i'm i'm hopeful for june but
microsoft from the day one from the day
i got that box from the second i got
that box it has shown its worth
to me and and hopeful to the future so
here's the first 20 years hopefully the
next 20 more
i know we won't have phil for the next
20 years
but i'ma say this love this space that
we're in now
because the the money before the money
was off it was like either the game
they were working on the games and then
the money wasn't there or
money was there and the games weren't
there this is a part right now
where the money and the games are
meeting
right and i know why dudes are fearful i
know that's why i had to say why is halo
hell to this standard
where call of duty nobody's worried
about this story you know
or or stuff like this i know the
frustration in that
because it's fair because
we're just saying we're just being real
like halo is held to a different
standard than any other first person
shooter on the market we're just keeping
it real
if if halo is to be game of the year
and it probably won't be my game of the
year right i'm going to keep it a buck
it probably it'd probably be a game i
love
but i don't go with the consensus what
other people do
but for it to reach that game of the
year status
it has to hit a lot of things i hope it
is
right i hope for somebody out there that
picks up that game
it's everything they expect it to be and
want it to be and i hope it sparks a
whole new generation
going forward for the next 20 years just
but
love the time that we love the space
that we in and
because this space might not be here the
next go round yeah you know
good point yeah i'll jump in um yeah i
mean king you got you killed that great
mostly all your
points um yeah for the first part 20
years xbox that's that's crazy right
it's it's nuts it's funny because as a
sega kid
same thing like you know obviously we
saw what was going on
and i immediately went b-line to
playstation it was no
shame in my game i was like well you
said
sort of no i betrayed say i i hit them
with the red wedding
when they did the 299 i was like
on behalf the sony playstation gives its
regard
and i was out and i was out and i
betrayed them because i was like this is
what i want i like these 3d graphics and
they were pushing stuff forward
so when xbox got announced i'm like
you know saying like what they doing
like
you know i thought they was fraud and
i'm gonna be front i ain't gonna lie i
was like
i don't see why they trying to get i
thought it was just trying to throw a
bag
and they wasn't really serious so when
it hit for me
it's obviously it's two things one
you drop on november 15th on the kid's
birthday
so it's like okay it's my birthday
then you debut in new york city bill
gates the rock
you know what i'm saying i'm like damn
it's kind of meant to be i
got a cop so you got that you know
and then as a techie i always loved the
platform if you're a tech if you love
advancements in tech if you love to see
how xbox always made me push forward
because it's like
hard drive in the box you know shout out
to crap i was on his show yesterday
with this you know ethernet it embedded
again not saying that it was the first
but they were the first to combine all
these things do it well
and at a high level then you got the
custom soundtracks that solves taking
i've ripped my whole albums into this
joint you know what i'm saying so
you got that then it was like let's be
real
like each generation iteration then it's
like 360 comes out
and it's like yo ken yo we got to get
rid of our big back tvs
you know what i'm saying 1780 eyes out
shout out to rick
yeah you don't say this hd
like we gotta get rid of the big back
tvs it's over no more 480i
when you saw 720 but we laughed at 720p
now but 720p
back then we were saying they were
saying that was the standard we were
like oh my god the fidelity look at the
jump
you brought someone over your house that
didn't have hd and they like oh my god
this is great i remember do you remember
mvp baseball two thousand five and seven
twenty seven
twenty p wide screen ice cream wide
screen
yeah that's when the tvs
it's so many iterations of xbox each one
forced us to learn tech og made your
network learn because xbox live
then it's like you got this and then
xbox live come out
oh boy you know what i'm saying i was
they killed outside of these walls
all right you can do it for the crib
we're talking we like y'all
then can you remember the first time i
heard you yeah
it did keep it real see these gamers now
you know saying no disrespect but we
come from them oh gee
call of duty lobbies them oh yes with
the disrespect
i love the racism some of my best
friends was racist
and you did not want to lose to these
dudes in these these lobbies
you know what i'm saying so nothing
nothing worse than talking all that
smack and coming back in that lobby
oh you just no i just stayed quiet you
got a whole lot he told me the most
disrespectful thing he told me
he said the reason why you can't shoot
your fingers too greasy from the chicken
yo i see you i said i got you i said
some racist stuff to him too
it was toxic yes but shout out he was
one of my best friends
shout out to xbox 360 now realizing how
crazy it got
remember they had regular they had
underground
they're underground yeah
one thing i don't like that they change
is the voice modulator
yeah talking like darth vader yes yes
i found out one one dude that we was
playing with
and i thought this dude was older yeah
it was a little kid little kid with the
voice modulators
yo remember your king will do a funny
one miss pre-connect
remember the xbox camera oh
remember
[Applause]
yeah so we we have people in the chat
asking if these people were real racist
or just racist no don't know
yeah some people and the thing is to be
honest
there were times like you know you you
have people that come in there
straight racist yeah and the fact that
you continue to interact with them
like honestly there were some people
that really changed
it's crazy to think about in that toxic
of an environment right but it happened
but it
definitely happened i had one do you
know um because we wind up one of his
people
switched off or whatever my team left
and i wind up going on his team
and then he started asking me like
questions because then you know
that they are not in the same
environment as
you and me how is it in new york yeah is
it a
yeah you would get that yeah and stuff
where are you from yeah
okay so and then that bridges the gap
that changes a whole lot of things
and and i can only attribute that to
xbox live
absolutely because again you had groups
of gamers
that would never interact with each
other from so many different players we
were so cool to hear someone over
overseas or over the world oh yeah well
you hear someone with an accent right
remember that was a big thing
where are you from you're from france
from you're from where you'll remember
remember to be honest with you yes
was that one dude in africa who light
was on you know you remember when you
looked at the map
and everybody who was on i forgot what
game the first time
was it 360 and you turned on xbox 360
didn't you show xbox live
showed you the world map it had one ping
in africa yes
yes i was like wow yeah i wonder it was
what's going on
it was transformed but just to finish up
you know they really
they really don't get enough credit for
each generation pushing the genre
forward as much as we laugh about
xbox one and and stuff but digital
gaming is where it ended up going you
know what i'm saying
like a lot you know fighting that i was
like i mean they invented xbox live with
the original xbox and then
and then with the 360 they was like yo
we we doing good but let
they they didn't just stay safe right
let's just let's just keep pushing this
third we're pushing
whenever making that 360. what can we do
make it better yeah
and then the blades and all that so
salute to them man the last point
obviously where we are now
you know what i'm saying say yeah all
these great things man salute to them 20
years of xbox
is tremendous i want to see how they
continue to celebrate it the halo
infinite thing i keep it quick you know
the game of the year stuff
does not matter to me i just want the
game to be good
i want a solid coherent campaign that's
not mishmash
i want a story that is told well do
serve it to him
long as hawk as long as adam gets his
hardcore multiplayer
and i wouldn't be opposed to uh either
if a battle royale style mode
gets added later or whatever they're
gonna do yeah like just you know appease
to all the bases try to make it you know
as accessible as possible
but that's what i got let's get these
last two let's double up and then get up
out of any superchats off
yeah we actually have a few hold on a
second
bingham five dollar super chat now that
book does there's more financial backing
for microsoft morgan freeman needs to
narrate the next four hours
that would be cool i would like that
actually i would like to there we go
slow mo backslash five dollars for chad
who won the debate song
thank you sour grapes for those who
enjoy bad controls great show as always
i don't i don't understand it right it's
not making
listen it just don't don't mistake me
giving you props for being a mass effect
encyclopedia
saying that you won don't mistake that
um
go enjoy your dating simulator oh my god
i love i'm not gonna even make comments
on mass effect success please
then we have urban ninja with the five
dollars of the chat again the man speaks
facts matter controllers god and halo
just like quake and doom long ago very
important very important then we have
brett bingham
five dollar super chat damn king you
took us down a dark road with sega
it was a dark road that's been it felt
bad for me i was
there from a long time yeah then we have
the wise old gamer we have a super chat
from him and we have a regular chat that
i wanted to read from the
wise old gamer um we got while gamer 20
years ago i was diagnosed with my first
case of cancer
my friends bought me an xbox so that we
could still play together online via
xbox live
i lost one of those friends recently uh
love to i love xbox for the memories
thank you to xbox other memories
salute brother uh we have drunken ninja
five dollar super chat gotta respect the
beard
built a next-gen console with almost no
hardware issues
shout out to the iron lords xbox live
alpha tester and the mayor
lord cognito one upping enrique on his
own show
yeah cause
fantastic show man these these old
bastards were tip of the spear
that's who we were yes we were pixel bit
g five dollar super chat
this is the first time in the history of
xbox that is not a side project
halo will be my game of the year based
on time enjoyed by me cheers
that's right don't let nobody judge if
you enjoy it
then we have flame with the 5 super chat
shout out to xbox for giving me the
first game i played and beat by myself
when i was a kid
that being fable looking at you
playground take me back
oh you know you know addiction
you guys think i've ranted in the past
they gonna have to come see you have
some stable dissertations
that same day we we about to get
disowned by everything
that's what i have to distance myself
from you when you're freezing yeah
you better do it man even since fave was
bad bad you better start dissing
yourself then
then we have the wise old gamer 5 super
chat i'm happy how xbox made more than a
box they made a community where
like-minded people can get together
before xbox we were solitary now we are
legion
okay and we got drunken ninja four
dollar super chat xbox really
revolutionized multiplayer yeah no doubt
you already know that is for sure i
think hold on a second
ninja yeah we're good we're caught up
all right cool let's get these two
quick hitting kind of bang bang yes say
kids ready
yeah playstation studios y'all you know
what i'm saying i was meaning to talk
about this shout out to uh benji sales i
think he put the initial thing out it
was all wired
and um yeah man looks like again they
have uh currently
25 games in development nearly half of
them are new ips according to
herman holst the gorilla co-founder uh
jim ryan tapped to lead playstation
studios in 2019
the group has more than 25 games in
development yeah so they basically said
that uh half from new ips and they're
definitely mayors
huh that's a smoking moment oh my god
okay so there's an incredible amount of
variety according to hosts incredible
amount of variety originating from
different
regions big small and different
genres so let's see this king wanted to
talk about this
so we're going king this is you
surprisingly with a saudi topic
so i when i came in today you know um
i was playing jay-z what more can i say
yes yes
stand up stand up you heard it
25 games over different genres
spending triple a to double a
new ips oh my god
it sounds too good to be true
don't even want to do it baby oh my gosh
so
just was looking at your little brick in
the corner with the dust on it
you [ __ ] down it's on baby they're
nothing so hard right now
i knew it i knew it when is the shoe
dropping
i said yo because you know last month
they was like yo we all about the triple
a and we don't care until you they
didn't like that
they didn't like that narrative that was
like
the people was like no like no
we we want we want everything so
they didn't like how it went all of a
sudden
25 days i told you
i told you man they lying
[Laughter]
we believe in triple a experiences and
that's what we're gonna focus on uh oh
they don't like that
yo we got mad 25 games the different
genres coming up
new ips they're gonna love how we do
this are you implying that there's mixed
messaging sir
i'm implying that they playing you
we exclusive we open
what are we really they frauding you
just like addicts said
is smoking mirrors they they always they
do this to you always and you always
gonna fall for it you always gonna be
boo boo the fool
they put out a little buddha they put
out a little tweet and tell you yo
we're doing this they made this leap
thing it leaked out
20 25 games leaked out man shut up so
they can't possibly be in development
no no you hear one game leak out from
some place
one right you you all you heard was
microsoft has a triple
a game that's gonna blow your socks off
one right of all 36
studios one game it's gonna leak out
these dudes have
a secret 25 game man shut up
how stupid can you be just just to sit
there because they don't want you to
move
they don't want you to go to where the
stuff is really at
some stuff really yeah they put out a
tweet with no pitches but no nothing
yo we got 25 games really
really man shut up
look like i'm not saying they don't got
25 games
and they didn't even really come out
openly and say what type of games
they're going to be they just said big
and small
it's going to be games like like from a
knack size to like a god of war
size all i'm saying is expect more games
in the middle than on the far end
because you know they they don't have a
whole lot of studios that do quality
work anyway they got like four maybe
five
no they they no i'm being real i'm being
real like a lot of these games are going
to be third party
uh third party timed exclusive i can
almost guarantee you this
but at this time unless they're going
back to what uh like you know to the
atlases
to the to the capcoms to the square
enix's who are they going to square enix
like
microsoft took sega's cooking what about
a third-party exclusive deals and stuff
like that no
that's what i'm saying like that you
you're looking at a lot of these games
from square
square enix like don't expect all i'm
saying
is they're going to have good games but
don't expect everything oh don't expect
like 25.
oh okay i get where you going
let me ask you let me feed into this all
right so what you're saying
is don't an addict it's like these are
not 25
triple a god of war ghost achievements
that people are thinking
that like they could fudge i'm going to
say that's a bad word but they could
skew the numbers with say okay summons
vr
some is indeed some summer's third party
deals something is that
a bunch of guys so instead of god
instead of 25. what's the word bangers
25 triple a
that's what you say that's
the thing is crazy is he said didn't he
say we have a development
right he's talking about playstation
studios so yeah if we're not talking
about third party
smoking mirrors 100 100
but they don't even have 25 studios
all right that's kind of true they got
shadow studios like what are they making
but but my junkable development you know
tim's best
titles but i don't think i don't i think
the communication was 100 there i think
he's talking about 25
titles coming to the ps4 of variety
originating from
different regions big small different
topics
lord herman i mean i mean we know that
they
they ain't known for their truthfulness
so you no but he's right about that
because the thing is
i'm i'm saying it's playstation studios
because there's herman house and they're
saying playstation studios
now he could be again but like alex said
he could he could be referring to
something that they paid for a year
exclusively i think they're helping out
with you know what i mean like
i mean we can't like that's not even a
down play some of the playstation's best
games came from other people
right even coming from bloodborne
persona 5
like so they're literally probably
besides god of war
they're the their best games are on uh
other people mate
they're saying playstation studios
that's what they twenty five
it's hard there could have been a lot of
uh interpretation going from writer to
like
was there an audio version or a video
version of this no just i said
we're going strictly off of what the
white yeah it's a miscommunication
we got to be realistic
if we got the decimal point it was 2.5
so if phil came out and said we got 50
games i believe him
oh yeah you know why i believe him
okay so you're just saying from like if
this is
the industry as a whole if this is like
all the people that they can work with
i could totally see 25 games easy and i
could see 25 good games
yeah but but if this is this is just
that
addict eight tops eight tops
no and then again you know what you know
what they could be talking about king
this could be the entire generation
yeah so i'll be playing that next
evening
but even at that king like god of war
took five years four or five years
horizon took like what four years
they're not built last of us took what
six years five years
i i got it
you know this king they're like yo
go over there and like in like quadruple
insomniac studio
because they're the only people making
games this five of those like spiderman
but to me cog no real to me the only way
that this works
is if all their studios do with a sony x
double fraction clay and spiderman
and i don't see a realm of possibility
for that i just don't
okay so when you know ratchet and click
is at 1080p
oh my god you're ridiculous we ain't
going to talk we going to keep that
resolution up don't be afraid oh my god
don't be afraid
you're ridiculous listen i get we just
don't get solved it i get what y'all say
yeah yeah
okay i i i somewhat understand where
you're coming from now i just was
curious but let's get solving
soft 25 man this this is not real
you either or not that it's not real but
i i think sony sony different to
microsoft
still it still feels like they can get
away with hyperbole
you know what i'm saying like if it
still feels like they can get away with
making these blanket big statements
and because in the end they always
deliver right that's what i'm saying
but you tend to forget the details of
like right you then you tend to forget
the details about it because again
when they deliver it's five years later
six years later but
um so i mean he could be talking about
stuff that's
being incubated and he said let's throw
that in there you know what i'm saying
this when you talk about 25 games in
development
and you think about sequels that you
already know are kind of in development
from
so you're talking about like 11 to 12
games right okay
that's a lot of new ips that you know
maybe don't even see the light of day
right because development is just that
way so it's a number to throw out there
that sounds nice
especially you know it's the new yorker
right now yeah no no i again i don't
they could be smaller games that could
be okay okay whatever the k
they could be any number of different
type of games right but like king said
when all that info and and to be fair
sony didn't say this themselves this
this is information that leaked out
which indicates this no no i'm talking
no i'm talking about the whole issue
with with them making only triple a
oh yeah that stuff came out they never
addressed that right right so so you
think let me let me cut you
do you think this is classic marketing
damage control post the jason schreier
for sure for sure 100 because that that
narrative came out
and we all talked about it like it's
straight up true and when you think
about
how successful they've been with their
big aaa games it would make sense that
they would be risk-averse to spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on
unproven properties it makes sense
so it it it makes sense that that would
be the truth or at least partially the
truth
so you you know that's where we get
these these ideas from
so the fact that they're if the truth is
that they still are making smaller
things
i'm happy about that because i like
playstation diversity i like that
same that's right i'm not buying nothing
else
yeah and i know that's kind of weird
i didn't buy i didn't get them i didn't
get them from there
don't listen to them sony don't do that
because you're gonna have a situation
like maternal
do not do that but then if they do if
they do
only do what you want you're gonna have
five games the whole generation
these dudes don't care anyway like attic
said most of these stuff come from other
places and he got that way
so at no point in time do anybody care
about them
doing the experience mental stuff
concrete genie
nobody cared nobody care for the five
people out there that's like i love
concrete
another thing another thing when we talk
about games and development right those
games in development how many of those
are vr games
yeah i was gonna say that now that i
agree with the philippines and how many
of that is dlc though
i mean let's keep it above stop we don't
nobody on this panel sit here and talk
about i want to see what they expect oh
god
i didn't even think about um
all right all right 18 of those games
oh
they don't got nothing to facilitate a
situation first of all we ain't
purchasing 25 games from them
right you know why because they have 70
dollars a pop
nobody's doing it nobody's doing that
nobody it's like it's like homeboy at
ign said they're going to make good
games
she's going to be expensive so let's
let's keep it real
until if they would have had something
like gamepad i'd be like
yeah i'll look forward to that do not
make 25 games
please focus on making this triple-a
bang
i'm down with that i want one every
other year
every other year so he said you you are
tim you are compliant with lord jim ryan
as opposed to
our ladies
and let's get down to brass tacks ah i'm
here for the bangers
just like everybody else all these
playstation dudes out here capping
they're here for the bangers ain't
nobody
they try to justify it nah man they got
mad different stuff man
it is a funny discussion now that i
think about yes they can
they can clearly skew the numbers if
they include vr
if they don't let's be real they're just
lying i'm not gonna go out
but you know um indie indie stuff you
know i'm a good number 25 let's go with
25 i'm not going dlc
at that point they should have just said
50.
even even if it is what y'all say
right i'm not always agree but even if
it is what y'all saying where the number
is just way too high for y'all right
till y'all believe y'all ain't feeling
it
okay my thing is at least what the jason
schreier article did
was put out to them the energy that yo
not even on kingdom like this that all
sunny fans was feeling
all we're going to get is blockbusters
and if a game like day's gone
quote-unquote succeeded but it's still
not going to get a sequel
that made sony fans upset you know what
i'm saying we had lord colin on you know
what i'm saying we talked about
you know that type of stuff too and on
his show so it's like at the end of the
day
you know i like to see that they're
still going to attempt
some diversity and we're not going to
get because my fear with them is yes
they got the bangers but i don't want
them to get into an old
xbox situation with meat potatoes big
mac
large fries and shake and you're getting
the same thing we're getting they turn
right i feel like they turn
i feel like you're going to get gains
from blue point because i think they
consider that them right like regardless
they're funding that studio entirely
that's them they just ain't
formally came out and bought them you're
going to get the studio that made return
all
right and like even if you put those in
and you put insomniac
slave trait that they do and they make
like four games
like high quality games like that's
still like
a good eight or nine short yeah i don't
want it that's going above and beyond
that i just don't want where everything
is the sequel now
right when you get in there gears i mean
what you're calling two
you know what cognito i got some bad
news for like i don't want that because
again that that is when i started to
have the issue
with xbox they put the right light on me
oh god i'm gonna have to do this this
is yours this is yours this is you
this is yours oh that's mine i'm gonna
hand it off to you i'm gonna put it on
youtube
yeah i want to hear this okay
let's be real let's be honest let's go
what do you want from them
i want their big triple x exclusives
but and what is that what i want new ip
though i want new ip as well
yeah i wonder why i don't want them to
be i don't want them to stagnate
come on did you did you finish horizon
no
hmm new ip did i finish ghost you see
him and platinum in it oh no no no no no
no
because they did what i wanted to do
god
[Music]
but i just want to be clear so just
because if i like it i mean if i don't
finish it that means i don't like it i
don't know how to say that i can't
possibly want sony to make these games
okay so okay what i'm what i'm hearing
from you you want 25 feudal japans
because i'm just saying that if it
according to y'all i mean not y'all but
according to you if if if you wanted the
banging the bang and then just stick to
the bangers that's that then goes to
sashima wouldn't exist and we would get
spider-man 4 and we would get you know
that studio wasn't making bangers like
they were making infamous and as much as
i like infamous
that wasn't there so they they moved on
allow
something else but what happens if ghost
sushi is a banger and then they just
start making ghosts
yeah that's the right unbeaten
uncharted we see that clearly spider-man
ratchet and clay they're getting sequels
and stuff
like right no i listen i get what you're
smarter
all i'm saying is i just still want with
the beauty of sony
is when they make an ip the beauty of
sony
well we will see what happens because
y'all don't believe the 25 okay this is
the only reason why i'm i'm i'm
attacking you any type of game
is this i purchased that console for
bangers this is my whole intent
though but this is this is my 500
yeah am i 501 bangers so yes i got miles
morales yes
i'm not gonna lie i like what it was but
it was dlc let's keep it a buck okay
and i would love the real game but i'm
cool with what i got
no doubt right and i'm waiting for
ratchet and that game that system has
not turned on again
you know it's it's down for the rest oh
it's funny
what i would just say i'm just waiting
for bangers to bang no i don't get it
when i first got my playstation i was
talking to king i was like yeah man i'm
a couple hours and miles i like he's
like oh so you're almost done
[Laughter]
look i get it and trust me i'm king as
much as i'm giving you a hard time and
you clowning me
i agree for me right now personally this
is no cap
and i've said this offline i've talked
to a bunch of people y'all know
right now for me yeah it ain't really
moving me my playstation 5 ain't really
moving me like right now
i will give you that right but what
excites me is when they
actually announce these type of titles
right or these new things
okay that's cool that's different i will
try that i'm excited about right now
i've never been really a ratcheting
guy so you guys are hyped for that i'm
not necessarily high for that and i'm
not really a dark souls guy like that no
disrespect to anybody who is
yeah so for me it ain't moving me i
agree but i just worry that if they get
into a thing where it's like dark souls
4 blood bro 2
you know what i'm saying then i'm like
well when i'm gonna get the diversity of
the games that i
don't that's all i'm trying to say i
think they're still gonna continue to
support
newer games right but i don't think
we're gonna see it anytime soon
because a lot of their core studios are
making sequels right now right and i
don't think they're going to make
sequels for the rest of their days
but right now for the foreseeable future
you're going to get sequels and then
like studios like the uh
the people who make return i keep
forgetting their names yeah uh house
mark you and then
you know whoever whatever blue point's
making right those
potentially you might see new ips but as
far as like
the the the quote unquote bangers that
they did and that's fine all of them are
making sense
because that's that's what they were i
feel you and you're absolutely right all
i'm saying is the reason why this
statement
excited me not that i believe the number
to the letter of the law
i just like that within 25 you got to
have diversity of half of them as new
ips
that's all i'm saying i just i'm just
feeling what the statement represents as
opposed to saying yo they definitely
gonna do
25. oh my god it's going to be crazy i'm
not i'm not i'm not doing that
so i feel y'all on that we will see
future looks bright and for the people
in the chat we'll say well why are you
so excited for xbox or whatever because
game pass is the ultimate nullifier for
me
that gives me the opportunity to try if
they had a return
style game you know what i'm saying and
they have different type of giant and
mlb the show and outright
why why why he acting like he don't know
why
don't you act like you don't know why
you happy fact it's not a
either or it's not a oh i like the way
the box look no
it's about the fact that they took my
one dollar and they stretched it off
facts
facts right and sony looks like they're
taking my one dollar and they're cutting
it in half and they're giving me one
game and telling me go about my business
and i want more porridge no now king
king they taking you one dollar throwing
it back in your face saying bring me 69
back
listen it's not for everybody some
people love that though so
give me that game pass every day yeah
you can do this i love you
no no absolutely i love gay basketball
i'm not even going to sit there in front
like games
that that to me is the ultimate
nullifier because even when
there's a drought see the problem with
the banger banger banger you got space
right so right so when there's a drought
i got all this stuff over here on
gamepad i can play
so that's why i've been on my xbox more
so far this generation anyway let's get
some chances more
yeah there's a gooser right yeah yeah
the last one you could get out of here
let's see this is super quick
so have you got a joint soft beauty
my apology oh let me see give me one
second
um i gotta run back a little bit
okay uh rrd with the two dollar super
chat favorite battle rapper i can tell
you watch
maybe the battle rapper yeah
the cannabis but he oh stop well he
for me is um hollow to dawn i like big k
i like a lot of the og's smoking i mean
locks of course locks of course
no deluxe of course it's crazy i love
the production he brought this
he's just a flare with the whole thing
with it
then we got flame too also but
playstation studio is also a publishing
house hint
yeah okay yeah they published uh mlb the
show on xbox
a shout out to the new publisher on the
block
they work is beautiful there we have
mass
racks with making 25 games to the
redesigned ps5 element
there we have clutch man five dollar
super chat once a week i wait out of
town
i wait out of town to bring a client
home shout out to xbox for giving us
little man that i could take in my back
pocket and game at panera
appreciates this i appreciate this trust
me yeah talk about the man on the go
they should have a show about that
little man
cause i just when we say little man i
think about like marlon wayans
we got smitty spent five dollars of a
chat ps5 games in development like such
is like such hits like what can i turn
it on
will rest mode work and rebuilding the
database the book
yo yo
down with petty sir that was pretty sick
wow that's for you all your pettiness
yeah we have jacob as a show
five dollar super chat if sony had 25
games in development
you know about it because sony likes
showing stuff very early like i said
yeah oh chris hart returned from eternal
too hard
christmas chris they're saying you
return fraternal is that true is that
true
they don't take it back so you stuck
with it
then we have beyond the river sticks
with the two dollar super chat
next thing they're going to say is fire
is hot
then we have jake mouseline mouseline
five dollar super chat i remember back
in 2008 meeting some brits and irish on
xbox live via college call of duty
following september i made a trip to
stay with him and experience britain
yeah they despite the toxicity on xbox
live
a lot of real friendship friendships
were born facts we're people that
you may not be friends with other facts
otherwise
we asked betty smith once again five
dollars with a chat uh all your sony
fans are excited for 25 games you aren't
going to purchase
damn damn y'all didn't even support and
won't be the show
wow then we have dan lazzaro two dollar
super chat 25 is possible when 20 are
remakes of remakes
[Laughter]
i mean we do have a last of us remake
being made yeah
i don't agree with it that's why i was
happy about here and i'm gonna buy it
though
i'm gonna buy it yeah i'm a fraud
i'm a
wait wait the remake the one with the
new faces right yeah that's what they
got i mean
they get my money though yeah i feel
like that's 70 cash
shout out to the gym dance moves ryan on
the street they can have your money uh
for that they don't worry about it
unless they change something like
narratively nah i don't like the
multiplayer i've never liked the
multiplayer level
yeah i don't care nothing about the
multiplayer i mean none of them are
playing it either oh my god i'm telling
bg on you
then we have mass wrecked two dollar
super chat
yo king hope your playstation 5 didn't
seize up from the dust
you know what that was crazy because i
got scared when i turned it on the other
day it was like
kind of catch on fire yeah please don't
do that i walk with a fire extinguisher
though
ridiculous continue there we have gamers
play with the twenty dollars we tap
the chat the chance xbox has no games
will be killed starting this year xbox
2021 the gunk starfield scoring the
ascent
12 minutes crossfire x forza horizon 5.
halo psychonauts 2 stalker
shout out to ako1 cop in the chat
first of all that narrative been dead
when game pass hit
because everybody that has a playstation
now is sitting there not playing nothing
and everybody that has xbox isn't on
twitter shout out
they said we fraud and they said we we
playing old games can't go on the chat
yes and then they got frame rate boots
and hdr y'all playing old games
like like when y'all put an old game in
it's a oh
she took that fight she took that flight
to colombia that's that's right
right flight to the dominican republic
good looking now
someone someone in the chat please clip
that you're playing
old games that's right she got that old
face
and that old style doing them old moves
frisco son with the five dollars for
chat uh brother
bought my son a hundred dollar psn
credit he didn't know what to do with
it he went to the store like oh like
nothing
oh my god what is this maternal
no then we have
geek head 188 with the five dollar super
chat
the ps5 is a dog water console what's
that one
water hot dog water yeah
inator with the five dollars of a chat
25 games equals 117 1750 usd
okay i got mine on the end of the
generation used with used games
all their games are single player
anywhere
so make sure you read the next one with
conviction
j.w five dollar super chat before i get
back to work at my house
i'm trying i'm trying i can't hear you
sir i i
just wanted to say mastermind
[Applause]
listen man i don't know taking punches
on the ropes to see if you're man
all right cool let's get about it this
one is super quick and uh
don't be an addict um you could like a
dragon man you know it was just reported
shout out to the belly and i think he
put the tweet out initially
and um yeah man so it looks like um
sega's
shouji utsumi told fomentu that yakuza 7
was the most successful title in the
franchise
worldwide he also stated that sega wants
to globally
explain atlas games by releasing them
simultaneously worldwide and possibly on
multiple
platforms so we got that and then i'm
not going to try to
butch butcher this uh japanese to
american translation thing
but pretty much he just said um you go
to go talk seven
you know basically um you know yakuza
joint is uh going to fully support
multi-platforms released overseas in no
time when it was previously
developed mainly in japan and
playstation is now available on xbox and
steam
however it received high praise there on
the global scale
yakuza like a dragon was the most hit
title
in the series so it looks like they're
very excited about
the potential of this kid seems like
he's bubbling at the bit about business
i got a question yes that wasn't game
pass right no
no actually it wasn't actually seven one
now the the
the all the other the dragon drone no no
it's not a gayp
i think that probably contributed to the
worldwide sales because everybody got to
tell you
if you got a chance to taste it like
maybe you might want that
to you to your point king yakuza uh
seven like a dragon was uh timed
exclusive
for the series x launch oh that's what
it was yeah he had it
first yes and they had to wait
and the sale they had to wait for the
ps5 oh okay
all right as i see it now i know now it
makes sense because i remember it was
something about
microsoft is the reason why it's a
global success and now they realize
oh my god we can make money over here
and this game pass thing is giving us
residual income
who did this for you at one point in
time
are you just gonna bend the knee just
give it up just who did this for you
feel dominance maximus are really
expensive and i don't care what nobody's
saying
all these other people don't okay this
is where you're trying to take the
credit from my man
stop yes sir listen it's a quarterback
in the team
if the team loses so did the defense i
don't care if the defense was the star
that day
the quarterback of the team is the
leader of the team
he is the quarterback so other things go
into it i don't care what that is
right here the quarterback he take the
wins and he takes the losses we ain't
gonna start pointing out little things
i like this yakuza stuff i like the fact
that they're gonna go all over thank you
to your defense um we did i i did being
addicted said
you know when you know serious sex was
down to launch times and stuff but
everybody got glossed over obviously
with the hail stuff but i remember
telling people that's a big get
like yakuza never would launch
honestly you ain't
it's a franchise i'll get to my point
quick before let me just jump in now
if you don't mind so i want to get these
balls real quick you know at the end of
the day like this make me happy because
y'all know i'm team turn
a team sega you know what i'm saying and
at the end of the day to see people
support this joint
was crazy inspiring to see it it's the
most successful
ever you know what i'm saying because it
went right was cool i want to see the
job and it was so much a success that
now they're saying
yakuza's going to stay in this mode for
moving forward
and then judgment is going to be for the
people who like the old yakuza styles
with the action
judgment is going to be the way for
y'all so they're not they
i got what i want i want it in this
style because it's the best turn base
for a casual person that doesn't like
turn pace it's action it's over the top
it's cinematic
it summons it's foolishness yeah and i'm
telling people right now
ichiban is the new wave bro like he
should be the face moving forward so
many people play this game
i'm mad at myself i didn't play that
launch because it would have been in my
game of the year
conversation that's how good this game
is game is sick but um
yeah i'm just happy for them man i'm
happy to see the genre succeed and i'm
happy that they're getting their bread
and now we're going to get you know
sequels and and all this good stuff so
that's what i got but i'll give i'll
open up to y'all you know which i want
to say on this job
um for me i just like the fact that
you know a lot of times when we talk
about people's perception of what
success is right
a lot of times you know we talked about
a game that sells five six million
copies and it's not a success
a success because of what's around it
right when you look at the days gone
you know it's like getting a sequel
whatever the case may be but you sell
six million copies to me
you did it right yeah um so it just
seems like
the fact that yakuza in a lot of ways
coming into this generation is still
very niche in the western market
for sega to see at the very least see
the appeal that it has now even they
haven't said
have they said specific sales numbers
are they just happy with it the
most highest selling okay
ever in the history of the franchise so
that could still mean
not not that much right it could still
mean not that much considering whatever
matters right
but the fact of the matter is that
whatever that number is they see that
potential for growth and they're going
to continue to expand upon it
and continue to put it out on the xbox
uh give the game to to markets that
didn't
you know that weren't getting it
beforehand to me that is the biggest
thing
right um the fact that yo yakuza for the
longest time
has been the shenmue replacement yeah
and
and it hasn't gotten that shine and when
you look at when you look at yakuza as a
game
and the things that it does better than
shenmue bro you appreciate it it's
crazy it's crazy and it hasn't gotten
that long i i gotta come in because
you said somebody would say it
[Music]
i hate to say this because i i supported
the shimmer but
like he just may be out the game too
long
and and these dudes you know i can't
find a
ryu gotta whatever i can't pronounce it
correctly but they
are literally the spiritual successor
this is the
truth that's what it looks like
evolution and
like that's their work so i mean addict
we talk about it i explain right now
like
it feels like a living breathing world
the job system they got that
the fun the cinema they got watching
your game i appreciate you talking about
inclusion and he said there's a thing in
there that you can build
businesses
are better than some people's for me and
attic was talking about remember that
businessman was like yo this could be a
real game and we'd be in it
because what i enjoy about it is like
they this is a fantastic first attempt
in the turn base like like i i still
think persona
overall is a better game in terms of
base
but like this this
is they came in with this debut they
didn't build up with this they came
in with this and and it did so well
that they was like who cares about that
oh
and you know we got it we got to hand it
off like i honestly i i made a video
about it i think game pass
has something to say with the cells that
that
led to this happening because to me when
it comes down to this
is the only the only variable there's
been a couple variables we've had a
turn-based variable change
from their standard to turn base which
to me that's a negative because that's a
more niche
audience of what they had the only big
narrative
is as xbox put all their games in game
pass
and now all of a sudden it's the
best-selling one right
man to king's point you know i know we
we joke and we laugh but at the end of
the day we we cannot ignore the fact
that this is on xbox
has something to do with it you know i'm
saying we cannot ignore that like it's
just
it is what and it's not on game pass yet
but
the entire other series so people might
be like you know what
because you know how many people have
come up to me and say yo that looked mad
fun when i put the clips up
and they go yo should i start with that
or could i should i start with the
gamepad and some people like yo going to
the old ones first
so you can get this on the story some
people say yo just go about it like it
is definitely
generating interest this has to be doing
well for say sega seems to be very
excited
to constantly blow v8 about all this
stuff going on with mark
and and i think the fact that you can
jump into this one brand new as a system
it's not intimidating yeah even though
they do call it seven i don't know why
they should have just
not put a number on it it's a standalone
story
it really is as a jumping off point for
somebody brand new
who may be intimidated by by going into
all the other games
it's right it does that but if you do
have that connection to the old games
it has that too right it has that too so
it just it really it cannot be
understated how important
it was to have that game as an exclusive
on xbox at launch
and to for you know and the thing is the
funny thing is when you talk about all
the outlets that talked about it
positively
everyone did yes but the focus was still
on
there's no halo we haven't like people
were saying we have nothing to play
but you have me you have an rpg you have
an rpg and
i'll be the first to be like i don't
have time to jump into this rpg so i'm
not going to play it at launch
even though i bought it and supported it
right but i didn't i
didn't have time to play it at the end
of the day all that's that that's
nothing but
fanboy talk like right like people have
wanted to throw this narrative out there
that people just play exclusives all
year long that's all they play
we know that's both
oh yeah not playing nothing on that
playstation if it ain't no banger
um but i don't even know why you are
because we got the metrics
that literally show what's being played
on xbox like you can literally go and
look at the bachelor so i don't always
no one's playing it because they don't
own it no one's playing it that's a damn
happening
i'm in that camp yeah and and i always
say this i mean
listen i'm going to get to that yakuza
stuff
because they literally have the whole
series
it's our game pass like all the old ones
that was never
there i'm so happy phil didn't give up
on japan
like i'm just so happy that that's a
gamer like if
if if if he didn't game he wouldn't care
to say let's get the old stuff back
there for these people
or whoever's there i don't care
whoever's decision it was
sarah barnes whoever the team this
phil's team
no oh fantastic yeah they own it and and
regardless how you feel about this
like i feel like one of microsoft's
biggest advantages they're going to have
going into once all these games start
coming out
is there going to be the place to play
rpgs regardless what type of rpg it is
oh absolutely they don't they don't need
to make
these japanese these jrpgs exclusive
they just got to make sure they come to
the platform they have a platform
because they
they can't be an rpg system right if
they're losing half the rpg society
about the dragon quest that's what i
tell people when they're joking
questions
next week uh there's going to be a big
press conference on dragon quest
oh yeah dragon quest build this is that
it's out there yeah game pass
doesn't it feel like this announcement
means like day and date though
yeah things that have traditionally have
been japanese
sort of playstation centric things or
feels like they're talking day and date
moving forward yeah i think shout out to
phil man
he was a great experiment for them just
to see
and now that they're getting these
returns and they're seeing this success
listen
six these companies want to make money
mm-hmm and when you see that bag
gotta shout out to phil like when they
drive and you you're getting
return on it it makes sense that's why
you're seeing them quick to throw the
whole series of big great man
to throw dragon quest yo it's a reason
and again for the people like oh
you know i don't understand there is
tons of stuff to play
if you're a game pass owner it's just
the fact
it's overwhelming like it's just like yo
damn i want to play this this came out
and this came up
it's so much so you can literally be
eaten
fine you know what i'm saying with just
that service it's just that much
quality games in there i think i think
everything coming out of japan is
starting to see a different look on xbox
like when you look at the chat mentioned
tales of verizon no doubt band band
dynamco looking at xbox like hmm
uh scarlet nexus when we see that it's
like hmm
you know it's it it feels like they
think that it's viable in a way that to
them it's never been before right
absolutely let's find out because i know
king got a roll on out
but look tremendous topic salute to them
again i can't pronounce that studio's
day for the life of me but i love them
real go logic wins tell me how it says
he know how to say it but anyway
anyway salute to the man tremendous uh
success good to see let's get the poll
with um we got super chats
xbox gave me the opportunity to play
halo couch co-op with my five-year-old
son who was now a pro
gamer long-lived the lan party's
long-lived blood goes
yeah day dub is a show five dollars a
chat i only bought yakuza like a dragon
because i played the older ones on game
pass
put over 100 hours in yakuza like a
dragon still
have the ultimate tower to beat yeah wow
absolute salute i'm almost there like
chapter 12
then we got gaming forte five dollars i
love
sundays i can always count on the lords
going over three hours
great job with your interview as always
and of course
hey king boo-boo hey forte
correctly ryu go to cool
okay ryu studio that's what i'm called
to go over thank you c-mac we're good
we're caught up
all right cool so look let's get up out
of here oh oh sorry
tony bryant five dollars in the chat
we're getting dungeons and dragons day
and date now that's right
i have a feeling we're about to get
persona five and then when they announce
dragon quest next
next week the night the new dragon quest
i have a feeling he's gonna say xbox
series snx right on that
with everything else no doubt shout out
just call them rgg [ __ ] all right
look noon poll coming out so um with
xbox's 20th anniversary
coming up this year in your opinion
which
feature of the xbox platform help push
gaming forward the most
the choices are a internal hard drive
custom soundtracks ethernet port of the
xbox
duke b xbox live and party chat system
for the 360 era
c back with compatibility
xbox one error and d you ain't got no
internet
we got a system for you
[Laughter]
those are the jerseys please rock the
vote when it goes up salute the lord
jason schrei who pulled
up in the realm of bloomberg news press
star
in stores right now check out that great
book and if you missed the other one uh
blood sweat pixels go check that out
had a fantastic interview again if you
came in late rewind
watch the first hour and a half man it
was it was a lot of fun a lot of real
talk
a lot of real talk so get to appreciate
y'all man and then
of course lord daniel may aka lord theon
great joy pulled up did his thing you
know what i'm saying
he's owning it now so i get the call of
that minus minus the ramsay stuff what
is the ramsey
let's cut let's cut them around today
let's let's keep the storyline there the
storyline yeah
man solution y'all's absolutely lit man
let's get these outros going lord addict
casually late for class today um where
can we find people find you
sneaking you can find me uh not sneaking
i was here the whole time yes you can
find me on twitter at lord addict iop
you can find me on youtube at gaming
addict uh this tuesday i'll be having an
attic show at 5 p.m eastern
so definitely look out for that i want
to thank uh
you know uh jason for coming on and it
was a good conversation
you know regardless how you feel about
the man it's like i said like
you don't have to like him but you do
kind of have to respect
because there's no one else doing what
he's doing let's just be real no one
else and no one else and to the point
like he said earlier like
there's a trust involved with that you
can't be spewing out stories if
you will get exposed very quickly in the
industry if your credentials aren't what
they are to be able to do it
and have people trust them so salute to
that lord
sovereign we're going to find people
finding what you're going on sir for
sure big shout out to jason mann i
always appreciate jason's candor
um and and you know and and we found out
some things about him today in terms of
you know
the willingness to talk to people and
forgive and the things that are going
online yeah shout out to him
i gotta give him we gotta give i'll peep
out people people together
we dated like two beefs two weeks
you know what i'm saying between jason
and paris and a couple other people with
jason
so shout out to jason who said look if
you
email me and if i block you and you
email me and you apologize
exactly and shout out to us man
i'm always proud of what we do every
week but i'm proud
proudest when we can do things like this
like you know and
you know shout out to paris for for
lurking in the chat and and bringing
that up
and hopefully like i said i i want to
have a more in-depth conversation with
jason later on about the state of the
industry where i will bring up
other names and hopefully we'll see what
can happen i didn't want to do that
today
i thought she was going to do it today
but i was like no no no
good call good call yeah yeah no doubt
uh so big shout out to that um yeah you
can find me no no stop iop
uh hopefully gaming a little bit more
um on twitter and of course bx albert on
psn and xbox live
no doubt you already know lord king
getting the the the crew the ranking
file to stand down
and stop hitting up jason salute to you
calling off the goons
i respect that great cookout yesterday
uh sir that was it was great to see you
and uh hang out
as always you know what i'm saying to
see the fans so silly what's going on
bro
it was funny because when cog walked in
it was like he was a rock star
and it was like hey it's cocked me
yeah so one dude taught me he was like
that's the guy that's on the show with
you
king's like i know
this has been a really nice weekend i
really loved it um
i really love real journalism
investigative journalism means that i'm
willing to get my hands dirty willing to
go
and get all the sources and get that
stuff together
that's like a lost art and yeah most of
these people
are not willing to pretty like low-key
fight multi-billion dollar corporations
yeah and shout out to jason schreyer for
being the boogeyman in a lot of these
dudes closets
you know yeah he'd be scared to to to
to be the white walkers and don't talk
don't talk to him probably got his face
up this guy
like a wanted poster i don't know that's
that's
insane and it is flattering because that
means you're doing your job well
you're doing your job well in a sense
but please i will i would really love
for them to go out and read this book
so then i actually know who he is first
before you are
you know pre-judge and and and condemn
the man ahead of time
um like he said a lot of dudes come at
him really weird and he said
you know they say some weird stuff but i
also love the fact that paris came on
and paris
you know was like yo whatever apology
anything for a man to apologize man
that's a big
fantastic you know to see in this day
and age
uh because a lot of dudes we hold our
feelings in and we don't actually
you know that ego put it to the side as
well um
i love you guys it was a great show yeah
and
last week i had to zip out of here real
quick you had a situation okay
yeah but um yeah man i can't wait for
next week uh
it's always a fun ride guys always a
writer
man like i said chat was absolutely lit
love what you guys said you keep
you're good i was just saying uh keep in
mind chat like that
the the those e3 shows are about to
start in the next couple weeks
prediction series will return you know
we're gonna have some fun with that um
yeah i guess again one last thing
shout out to earlier on the chat because
you know obviously
iop has different guests different
perspectives you know not everyone's
gonna like everyone but to see everyone
still
show out and for the most part be
respectful you know we had to cut
cut a couple of heads off right hustle
you know what i said but other than that
it was good to see it and people
just come together with gaming and be
respectful so salute to that we always
going to champion that and
my motto is like i said if the guests
ain't the one of your liking this week
we'll see you next week
that's just all we got man but um oh
hustle oh yeah
bro you want to do the e3 with us yeah
yeah we do the live stream sure for sure
i got you hustle no doubt you already
know what it is so look that's what we
got
more big ass more fun stuff stay tuned
keep it locked
you know what i said but that's all i
got we got to get kicked out of here we
got
one super chat i'm going to end on this
philly eagle 5
super chat i love this podcast
feels like family every single
time biggest compliment you can give us
thank you the realm is family yo
check y'all next week we out of here
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you